so you're a complete beginner in the
architecture industry you've probably
never used Bim software before let alone
archicad well this video right here
today is going to train you from start
to finish in intricate detail and depth
to show you exactly how to use our CAD
like an expert what's going on team my
name is David Thomas I'm a registered
architect here in Western Australia and
this video is for all the beginners out
there looking to master archicad now
let's stop looking at my face let's turn
to this screen and get started with one
of the longest videos I've ever produced
to date welcome to your very first
archicad 26 tutorial and part one of
this completely free course now today on
a little bit under the weather so I
apologize if my voice is a little bit
nasally and a little bit sniffly but
we're going to try and get through this
in the best possible manner so whilst
you have arcad 26 open you'll see the
very basic new map and nearby First of
all you're going to see a few markers in
the middle and you're going to see your
generic outline of all of your toolbars
and workspaces now I want to get you
familiar with what you're seeing right
here on the screen so let's take a deep
dive very quickly into the interface of
icad 26. first of all you're going to
have all of your elements up the top
including file edit new all of the
basics that you're most familiar with
you may or may not have CI tools and 4D
Library installed these two are
additional add-ons that I've personally
purchased and added on to make arcad a
little bit better we'll dive into all of
these a little bit later first of all
all you're going to really want to do is
tap on the window button come down to
toolbars and make sure you have the same
elements clicked as I do so we want
Australian drafting AIDS and we want
standard this will most likely say
International drafting aids for you not
Australian it just depends on what
template you have open and available
next you want to come across down to the
palettes section and make sure you have
these four selected at the same time we
also want to turn on Renovations and
Trace reference so I'll hit Renovations
come back up to window
palettes and also hit Trace reference
you'll see that Trace reference has
landed in the middle of our screen so
what we want to do is Click drag and
drop that into the palette on the right
hand side now we have our palette there
and we have our renovation layers at the
bottom to continue familiarizing
yourself on the left hand side you're
going to have this basic window and
Palette you can drag it further and
wider or you can simplify it by dragging
it shorter personally I like it in a
double format but you can have it
however you like so what we're going to
see on the left hand side is most of our
design and workflow tools so we're going
to have our walls our doors our Windows
our slabs and our objects as well so
this is the main palette you're going to
be using most of the time and if we
click on one of these elements you'll
see that the top toolbar completely
changes with all of the different
elements available to you for that
object I'll hit escape to exit out of
that menu so we can continue with the UI
down below you'll have the document
section which is a little bit more
Technical and we'll get into that later
but mainly here you have your grins you
have your text tools your line tools
polylines bubbles clouds and Camera
tools so these are more often
documenting as per the title and they're
not really used at the start until you
get a little bit deeper into arcad we
mainly focus on the design elements at
the top you're going to have your
windows up top as well so the more
actual Pages you open the more tabs you
can have at the top arcad is not like
Rhino it is not like Revit you can't
have multiple windows side by side so
even though if I try to click and drag
this 3D window it's not going to let me
actually open to side by side you can
only have one open at a time so on the
right hand side let's say I click on
this elevation you'll see it will open
up another Tab and we'll have the three
tabs open any one go you can keep as
many open here as you want it doesn't
really affect your performance too much
but if you have a large project I do
suggest keeping it pretty minimal and
closing those elements as you work
through now on the right hand side we
have basically our organizer and the
best way to work through archicad all
your layers all your maps all of your
different viewpoints including
elevations and sections
now what you'll see is at the top we
have four different icons we have our
name organizer which is our project map
we have our new map we have our layout
book and finally we have our publisher
sets all of these are quite Technical
and quite detailed so first of all your
project map is going to show you
everything and anything you could
possibly have in your project whilst
your viewmap on the other hand is going
to be defined exactly how you like it
and how you want it to be set out so for
instance you'll see that there's
different layers in the Australian
tablet including sketch design the pages
you would typically export for sketch
design for construction development
documents same sort of system structural
plans ceiling plans all of the pages you
would typically have laid out now you
can create new folders on this side you
can do whatever it is you want on this
side by simply going down to the bottom
and saving a new Point cloning a folder
or creating a new folder in its entirety
it really depends how you want this
structured and set up but for a beginner
it does not matter too much because
you're going to format it in the layout
book this is all going to be here just
to kind of make your life a little bit
more organized and a little bit easier
if you think about Photoshop you can
think about the layers that's really
what this is here so speaking of layers
archicad is a layering system if you
press command or control L it will open
up the model view layers just like
Photoshop you're going to have millions
and millions of layers and you're going
to be very careful when adding new
projects to layers themselves so as you
can see the template is quite detailed
and it has everything pretty much broken
down into every layer you could possibly
need beams exterior General interior all
very very generic but enough for you to
be able to actually put the right things
in the right layer you'll see on the
left hand side we have all sorts of
different layer combinations which are
basically attached to your view map so
if we close that come back into our new
map open up any of these sketch plans we
can right click view settings on out
site plan and you'll say that layer
combination is 100 planned site so if I
close that command L again you'll see
that if we were to double click on the
site plan it would only show us these
layer combinations whereas if we change
the sketch it would show us a different
layer combination now this is critically
important when you're changing pages and
layouts so when you go from a site plan
to a floor plan to an elevation you
don't necessarily want to see all of
that information on site plans typically
you don't need to see the internal walls
on floor plans you definitely do so you
want to make sure that each layer
combination is perfectly set up for each
section in each page we can stick to the
defaults here just because it makes life
a hell of a lot easier and when you get
a bit more experienced you can tweak
this play with it update it change it so
for instance on the site plan if we
wanted to see the ceilings we could
press the little I button turn on
ceilings and then hit the update button
so that whenever we went back to the
site plan all ceilings were visible but
I don't want to do that so I'm just
going to click cancel and move move out
of that space now focusing on this
Central UI in the middle which is our
main workspace and our main environment
if you zoom in a little bit using the
mouse scroll wheel you'll see we have
two in different markers here first of
all we have e01 and we have S01 by
default e will stand for elevation s
will stand for Section if you completely
new to architecture an elevation is the
external of the wall it shows your
facade your architectural treatments it
doesn't go too much into the
construction details whereas a section
will actually cut through a building and
indicate what kind of construction
methodology you're planning so is it a
slab on ground is it suspended Timber
what kind of roof structure Etc so both
of these serve different purposes your
elevation will talk about your
materiality this section will talk about
your constructability down the bottom we
have our toolbar that gets changed very
seldom one of the main things you might
change is your scale bar so in your
workspace here in the model view you
will be working to a one-to-one scale
meaning if you measure one centimeter it
will be one centimeter but if you export
that page into a layout book it will
show it as a 1 to 100. if you want to
change that you just simply click on the
change scale and change it to whatever
scale you're looking for now if we come
into our view map across on the right
hand side and drop down to the ground
floor presentation plan you'll see some
things change the style and color
changes that's not too important at the
moment what is important is let's say
the scale is 1 to 200 and we wanted to
make it one to one hundred we drew
everything updated it showed it exactly
how we needed to and then double clicked
off that page came back to it and
realized it was 1 to 200 still in all of
our settings were messed up we simply
just need to drag it back to 1 to 100
zoom out a little bit so we can see
everything in that page come across the
settings here where you will see the
little warning icon this warning icon is
telling you that the settings are not
saved and when you exit this page it
will revert back to default if you don't
want that to happen simply click on the
settings button go get current window
settings press OK and it will revert
everything to your current settings so
even if you simply zoom in it won't be
saved to that Viewpoint if I go back to
the first plan and the second plan it
will change it accordingly the last
thing you need to familiarize yourself
with in the UI is the actual layout book
and this is where we export to a PDF and
be able to actually present it to people
so if we come across the layout book
let's just go to a100 ground floor plan
you'll see that arcad has a default
layout set up ready for you to go and
utilize as you see fit we'll go through
how to update this actual workbook and
change the title block and everything in
between in another part but for today
I'm just simply going through a generic
UI so as you can see by clicking on this
little section here it is showcasing the
ground floor at 1 to 100 scale if you
right click and select update it will
update that and show whatever is
available on the ground floor plan we
haven't drawn anything so it's still
blank and only showing our markers top
right hand corner we have a first
introduction of our schedules which is a
little bit more of a technical Advanced
feature we may or may not get into that
into this tutorial but it is a very nice
feature to have and something we can
detail later on down the track at the
bottom you'll also see this hashtag sign
with project name that is basically
telling you that this is an automated
feature same as drawn by same as project
ID and it will populate this information
automatically based on information you
provide so to change that file info
project info and you'll see we have all
of these project info description boxes
if we go project name and title this
free course press OK you'll see the
project name completely changes so if we
come back file info project name we can
continue to update all of this info
animation one by one and it will
populate to the relevant Fields now you
don't have to populate all of it you can
only populate the items that are
actually required to you so for instance
if you only want to document what's in
the title block you can update your
project number Status client client Zone
win region site and it will populate all
of those things down below if we don't
want that free course to be there again
simply delete it press OK it returns to
project name now that is the base
introduction into arcad 26 day one part
one if you've never used this product
before there is so much that can be done
with this program in such a short period
of time so for instance I could quickly
draw a shape go into 3D and my walls are
already done we'll begin modeling and
talking about how to actually create a
3D architectural Masterpiece in archicad
in part two going to progress with our
course today we are going to be
exploring the site mesh and modeling in
archicad 26. now point out one I'm still
sick so I do apologize for that two site
modeling and everything that I show in
arcad 26 is convertible across all
archicads basically the new ones that
come out are CAD 23 4 5 you name it it's
pretty much all exactly the same thing
so what you want to do is if you have a
DWG available from feature surveyor drag
and drop that into your project right
now I'll quickly drag one in and get rid
of any confidential information okay so
now we've dragged DWG in from the
surveyor and sometimes it comes in color
sometimes come from black and white it
really depends on the surveyor itself if
you don't have one this isn't going to
be too critical for this stage of the
actual works you can basically still
follow along the same steps and
procedures this just gives us a bit more
of a bounding box to design and work
with so I've dragged it in first of all
and it is not to scale at all what we
want to do is first select the whole
thing zoom in press command K to
activate our resize tool press OK and
then find a dimension so for example
here 19.5 is our front boundary so what
I'm going to do is zoom in to one
section
come all the way across by zooming in
and out using my scroll wheel click on
the second point and then you'll see the
line starts to extend but nothing
happens what we want to do is type 19
500 because this is in millimeters not
meters and then press enter if we now
zoom out our feature survey is
completely to scale in both formats
please take note that with archicad you
can only scale in both directions at
once you can't scale just in One
Direction so if it isn't formatted
correctly if it's Shrunk the wrong way
you're going to have a bad time now that
we have our site to scale what I'm going
to do is select all of these markers for
the sections and elevations that are
basically in our way now by holding
shift and clicking on each of them
individually next I'm going to press
command or control x d depending on
which system you're on to move them out
of the way
now before we start using our mesh tool
over here we want to make sure that our
site is set up correctly so we don't
have any problems later on for this
project if you're looking at it 6.4 6.2
your rough ground level for the house or
whatever you design on this would be
anywhere from 6.4 to 6.3 if you're
building on natural ground so let's say
we're going to use 6.4 as our floor
level and then basically fill some more
sand in front of it what we need to do
is come up to archicad go down to
project preferences and then scroll down
to reference levels when the little
pop-up opens you're going to see project
zero elevation zero first reference
level is zero second reference level
zero and all the same
what you want to do is actually change
the first reference level so we want to
change that to minus
6400 and press enter y will all make
sense in just a little minute now it's
time to come across to our mesh tool and
start using this I'm going to make sure
you get into very good best practices
from the start in arcad first thing you
want to do is make sure you're looking
at your layers what layer is this on
where is it showing and why mesh site is
automatically default to mesh site which
is perfectly fine it isn't visible so as
you can see the eye is crossed out and
gone because we're on the wrong view map
as you can see we're on the ground floor
presentation so obviously they don't
really care too much about the site now
I have skipped a step to be completely
honest and that was by not putting this
feature survey on the right level so
let's quickly just select all of the
feature survey and change the layer
to cite context and press ok now if we
double click on our site plan increase
the scale from 1 200 to 1 to 100 zoom
out a little bit press our settings get
our current window settings as discussed
in part one we can now come to our mesh
tool see that our mesh site is activated
and then we can choose one of our four
objects here we can go from polygonal we
can go rectangle we can go rotate a
rectangle etc for this we simply want to
go for the polygonal and click around
our boundary so zooming in making sure
we're selecting just that green line
following the procedure and process all
the way around clicking once more at the
very end now what you'll see is if I
zoom in you'll see the difference of
each line thickness and it gets a little
bit messy in my opinion so personally
what I like to do is come up to view go
on-screen view options and then untick
true line weight so if I untick that it
is much cleaner much nicer they are all
the consistently same pen weight and
I'll only turn that back on when I need
to cross check pin weights now I have a
lot of experience with the pen weights I
know which ones to use which ones not to
use so this isn't always recommended for
beginners but if you do want to change
it it is up there just true line weight
on and off now if we click in the middle
of our site it will highlight that mesh
immediately and if I right click show
all in 3D
double-click my scroll wheel it will
Center my site and you'll see amazingly
it's created a 3D site grass on top
Earth down below and we have a big
rectangle nothing special nothing too
fancy but obviously we need to make this
proper and we need to make it look
exactly like the site itself so let's
come back to our site plan select the
mesh go back to our mesh tool making
sure that we are on the polygonal tool
because this doesn't work very well
otherwise holding your spacebar allows
you to use the magic wand tool the magic
wand tool can be used in a number of
ways and we'll discuss more ways as we
progress through the course but for this
use case we're basically going to hover
over one of these contour lines click OK
and click ok so then we're going to
repeat that for every contour line on
this feature survey luckily there isn't
too many there is only a couple so now
what that's going to do is basically
create hotspots and nodes that we can
adjust the levels and Heights of this
mesh
so by clicking on it you'll see hundreds
of them by going back to 3D you'll see
the contour lines drawn in in 3D as well
and hot spots available
if you simply want to mess around with
it in 3D you can select any of the hot
spots look for the little pop-up toolbar
select the little Z Arrow which is
Elevate mesh point and you can drag it
Up drag it down do whatever you want and
it adjusts the mesh accordingly so I'm
going to press Ctrl command Z or Zed
however you like it undo that command
come back to our site plan select our
mesh zoom in a little bit understand
that this corner is
5.94 so I'm going to select the corner
and do the same and instead of going to
mesh reference plane I'm going to go to
First reference level which we changed a
moment ago
you see that we had to go minus to be
able to actually get this in positive
territory in archicad
so 6400 is our zero zero ground level
but we want to adjust this to 5940 press
Ok We're going to repeat the same steps
for all four corners because they're
quite simple and then we don't really
want to go through each individual
little node and change them all to six
thousand six thousand two hundred
because that would just drive us all
crazy so we are going to select one we
are going to change that back to First
mesh level we'll simply type in 6000 and
make sure we select apply to all and
press ok I'm going to repeat the same
process for the remaining Contours and
then when we're done we can come back
into our 3D site
now zooming around by holding shift and
clicking the scroll wheel we can see our
site is relatively flat yes absolutely
but there is a slight fall from the back
left corner over here to the bottom
right hand corner over here now this is
just our existing sight mesh if we come
back to our site plan itself you'll see
we also have a little bit of an extended
Verge here we have the curb from the
road and then we have the road itself
now obviously I know this site well I
have the PDF information which has a bit
more confidential data on it to tell me
that this is the road this is The Verge
Etc so I'm making some informed
decisions here at the same time I know
that these three lines are services to
the property for example this I know is
water because it is labeled as water
this is also water and the last one is
gas now if you wanted to change them to
different colors just so you can
delineate what is what you can quickly
go through change the colors so you know
you've got water most likely sewer and
most likely gas what we want to do is
model bit of our context as well so that
when we do three these later down the
track we have a little bit modeled we
know what's going on
so by holding our option button we can
activate our eyedropper tool select our
mesh click once create our extended mesh
to the curb and then finish off our
rectangle coming back into 3D
you see it's created a new flat mesh
following the same principles so back
into our site plan simply follow those
steps adjust our Corners accordingly and
you see it's updated to reflect that now
there are also contour lines here if we
wish to go to that extent so same system
hold the space bar click click click and
update the nodes and there we go that is
quickly tying back in so it looks very
seamless and clean we can repeat that
same process for the curb and the road
and next we'll start talking about
materiality in our site mesh now that
we've modeled our curb and our road
you're going to see one thing different
about the road first of all the road is
just a millimeter thick it has no
context to it underneath which is a
little bit strange compared to what
we've drawn before specially if we look
up the top here where it says 1 000
millimeters deep exactly the same as all
of these now arcade will show you this
exact scenario every single time it if
your Falls across the mesh you've
created are greater than one meter so if
you do need to see the Earth underneath
whatever reason simply increase that
depth and it will automatically create
something for you so by adjusting that
one thousand to three thousand we've
managed to get our Earth back now
obviously this site isn't all grass we
know the roads aren't grass we know the
curbs aren't a grass so let's start with
our road if we press command T to open
up our settings we're going to see all
of the mesh settings now I'll run
through these relatively quickly to give
you an in-depth understanding of what
they are first of all we already spoke
about this the 3000 indicates the depth
of the mesh the zero indicates its
offset from this home story The Home
story in this instance is ground we'll
talk about these home stories in the
next part of this tutorial our project
zero is zero which if we change to First
reference is six four and then we have
our actual composition types if we
select soil you can change change it to
any other composition you do want to
make sure this is relatively consistent
to the products you're using because it
will help you as you dive deeper so the
more good habits you pick up now the
more you will thank yourself in the
future I'm happy to leave it as soil for
now it's not too big of a deal I won't
talk about pens and line weights and
correct combinations and because there
are so many viewers from around the
world there are a number of different
combinations of how this can be set up
yes there is a generic standard that
everybody should be using does everybody
do that absolutely not arcad by default
does provide you with what they should
be so if you scroll across you can see
that it's changing its name up the top
here and the more you spend on here
you'll recognize what pen they should be
and what line weights they should be
archicad is again pretty good it will
automatically change these to what they
should be so 153 is already set up by
default as Earth cut lines which is
exactly what we're looking for I'll come
back to this model section in just a
minute however this classification
section down below is going to be really
important when you're creating schedules
especially for doors and windows so make
sure it's always in the right
classification your IDs are for your ID
markers and tags which allow you
basically to model appropriately and
then provide information back linked
accordingly you can go through all of
these import update and correctly
address them but these are some pretty
substantial and very Advanced Techniques
in archicad so for this course we will
not be going in to anything of this
depth and magnitude now you see three
images here on the side the top surface
the side surface and the bottom surface
the top surface is overridden which
means we can automatically change
whatever we want that surface to be if I
untick it press OK it will change it
back to soil for the very simple reason
command or control T to open this back
up it is defined as soil and that has
its own textures built in to the model
material so by coming back to our
topsoil selecting grass we can come and
change this to whatever we want if you
start typing in Asphalt you'll get
asphalt dark and asphalt light asphalt
light perfectly fine pressing OK we can
see that automatically change to a road
if we wanted to repeat that same step
for the curb and make sure the curb was
dark we could do that as well and then
we have a light Road a dark curb I'm
pretty certain this will remain as grass
or some sort of landscaping but the site
as mesh existing will definitely not be
grass it will be turned and flipped and
rotated dug everything in between so
it's most likely going to be sand of
some sort sand beige perfectly fine
press OK and there you go we now have
four different textures on our mesh one
for the road one for the curb one for
the verge of being grass and of course
our actual site as well if you wanted to
go ahead and model all of the
neighboring sides extend the road and
the curbs across put some fences in you
absolutely could with the feature survey
information you even have details of the
houses next door where their pools are
you could jump on Google Maps document
it and be able to import it in to your
3D renders at the very end however for
the purposes of this tutorial we're
going to focus on just this site and
just the mesh itself One Last Thing
Before we wrap this tutorial off we're
going to press command L and open up our
layers tool you're going to see that we
have a site mesh but we only have really
one site mesh what happens when you
start cutting filling digging moving and
changing the actual parameters of the
site well what I'm going to do is Select
our mesh site come down to rename and go
existing now what I'm going to do is
actually create a new layer as well it
won't let me create a new layout whilst
I'm searching so I'm going to exit out
of that tap new go mesh Dash site post
click off it and then make sure that I
select our plan site scroll down
activate the eye and update our layer
combination pressing ok now when we come
back into our site plan I can hold my
option button grab my eyedropper tool
change my mesh layer from existing to
proposed click Once on This 6-4 contour
line and go to our end and finish off at
the top of our 6-4 contour line circle
around it finish off our shape and our
texture what I now want to do is select
one of the end nodes go to our subtract
from polygon and hold the spacebar to
subtract and cut out all of these extras
which we don't need because they're
outside of our six four and there we go
now our mesh is perfectly cut into that
six four parameter I do still want to
slope it a little bit I don't want it to
just bank at 6 4 all the way and have a
big 200 300 mil Gap here so what I'm
going to do is introduce a couple spare
nodes over here make sure these back
ones are sticky 4 and then I'll adjust
just these two corners in 3D so coming
back to 3D you can see our proposed site
mesh there I'm simply going to drag that
one down and drag that one down to match
our mesh so now we have a relatively
flat site at six four that we can
utilize for the purposes of design good
practice honestly would be just to put
this 6 4 mesh underneath the house and
allow the house to step down to six four
so that we didn't have to retain any of
these sides however we're just assuming
that there's an endless budget we can
retain quite easily we can Bank we have
no issues with her neighbors do you know
where we left off we're going to come
back to our site plan up the top and
realize that we've modeled everything so
far what we're going to do is plan out
our house plan out our spaces using some
2D documentation tools and then move on
to some more complex 3D elements so
instead of sticking to the site plan we
don't really need to know all this extra
information we can come across to our
ground floor presentation plan double
click and press command or control L to
open up our layers now as you can see
plan sketch still showcases our actual
survey Contour information below which I
don't want it to so I'm going to type in
site go to site contact unselect that
eye and then go update pressing ok I'm
going to see all that information
disappear and notice that this is all on
the wrong plan as well so I'm going to
highlight all of this information move
that back to site context layout so it
all slowly disappears come back to my
site plan grab my boundary lines and
move them off the site context to the
text in general layer so that when I
come back to my ground floor
presentation I still understand where
our boundary lines are if you wanted to
skip that step you could right click on
site plan go show as Trace reference and
then you would see the highlighted Trace
reference below of your actual site plan
now you can change the colors of the
trace reference here so if you wanted it
to be a very different color to what is
this brown underneath you can also
change the opacity of the layer below as
well if it's a little bit of a too much
of a contrast for you moving on we're
going to come to our fill tool and just
use our general fill to put some spaces
and some shapes together so starting off
we need to actually come into our site
so we need a driveway we're going to
start from our road come up all the way
to here understanding that the local
codes push it back approximately six
meters we want it six meters coming back
down and pressing enter to finish off
our Square you see it is a very black
dark square but that's because up top
our settings are appropriate for what
this is
we want to make it something different
so we're going to change it from Cut
fuel to drafting fill first of all which
then allows us to edit these colors
quite easily secondly the foreground and
textures are all set up by default in
arcad personally I want to see
everything below I want to see it
underneath so I'm just going to change
that to 25 for now and leave it at gray
with no fill underneath so this allows
it to be transparent and this allows the
window behind a scene
if I wanted to have a color underneath
for example an orange I'd simply click
there and the base of that would be
orange
command or control Z undoes that
completely now this fill may or may not
be in the right position for you so
let's select this fill and to move it we
have one of two options we can either
select one of the hot spots and this
floating toolbar will appear we can
select our drag tool here which allows
us to move it freely or if we press
Escape select it once more we can press
command or control D and then press
anywhere on that shape to move it as we
say fit for me personally I'm going to
select it press command D select one of
these nodes hold shift come all the way
to my boundary whilst holding shift
press the D button for distance then
type in 1500 and press the minus button
by doing so it will automatically
calculate the 1500 millimeters distance
from the boundary and I can press enter
and it will move it across for me now
this is just space planning it doesn't
need to be perfect so I'm happy with the
fact that it doesn't align with the
Curve exactly as it should next we want
to hold our option or our alt button and
select our fill tool we're simply going
to change the color so we have something
different and come across the top here
to change to our rectangular method so
pressing once will start to create your
rectangle tool I'm going to press the
tab button type in 6000 tab 6000 and
press enter that creates my 6000 by 6000
garage space or carport
if my memory isn't too good and I want
to make sure I annotate things as I go
along I can simply come across to my
text tool click once click twice
turn caps lock on for me personally type
the word Garage in change the color
change the size change the formatting
and drag and drop that approximately in
the middle now I choose to do this with
just generic 2D fill lines at the start
because it's very easy to delete change
and manipulate if you're a little bit
more advanced and know what you're doing
you can probably also come across and
use the Zone tool so the Zone tool up
here is very similar to our 2D feel so
if I come across here draw my Square
press enter you'll see it creates a Zone
name it gives you the area it
automatically compiles everything within
and if you open up the settings by
pressing command T you could change that
to garage change the Zone number to zero
zero or whatever your future schedules
are press OK and you'll see it
automatically changed the garage and
gives you an area
now this is more of an advanced
technique so we won't go into too much
of that right now we'll stick to this
information here this isn't going to be
specifically a design tutorial so I'm
not going to go into too many shapes
objects rooms it's not going to have any
principles behind it it's simply just
going to be quick massing sizes to
create an architectural form and shape
so you can understand the basic
principles of archicad
so once again let's press the option
button change our color to something
else let's create a large foyer entry so
let's go two and a half by two and a
half push this back maybe a meter meter
and a half once again duplicate change
color so we can create some sort of
bedroom spaces living spaces so let's
create two of those in here by copying
duplicating across relatively quickly
we're going to create a large six by six
playroom games room or anything of those
sorts and push that two meters back so
that we can introduce our staircase to
our second floor here
we're then going to select our foil
press the command or control D button
select one of the hot spots and then as
you see it across you see a tick next to
the arrow if you press the option or alt
button you'll see a plus come up which
allows you to duplicate it once if you
press option and command together you'll
see two pluses come up which will allow
you basically to keep clicking as many
times and create as many copies as you
need
so let's delete those entirely select
that foyer once more command D option
once let's create one bathroom here
let's duplicate it once more extend it
by a meter to create some sort of
laundry potentially over here
extend it in a little bit more so it
aligns with that bedroom reduce this
hallway spaced 1500 select this hotspot
go to our plus button zoom in to the
alternative corner so that we can simply
drag across automatically snap to the
oranges hotspot press OK on the mouse
and it will update that space there now
in this design there's a lot of waste of
space like I said it isn't a design
tutorial whatsoever it is a very very
basic masking and shaping so if we were
to change this this could be a games
room three bedrooms downstairs we could
have a bathroom here and finally we
could have some form of laundry or wet
area here and then of course our stairs
will come
into the design later on as we're
actually duplicating and creating so
you'd walk in you'd have a nice large
glass window here sitting directly to
your backyard
beautiful pool manicured lawn whatever
you wanted in the rear Landscaping so
there's a direct connection through
indoor and outdoor a very simple ground
floor plate a very small ground floor
plate in that fact and then most of the
living upstairs now that we've moved on
to the fact that it's going to be a
two-story house what we're going to do
is press command or control seven and
you'll see we have some of our story
settings so first we want to rename some
of these we're going to go ground floor
let's go 2745 because that is a typical
timber frame plus plate next we're going
to go ground ceiling we're only going to
allow approximately 300 for this space
in between those floors then we're going
to go first floor
we're once again going to allow 2745
we're going to introduce a new one above
go first a ceiling that we're going to
do as 300 once again one more roof plan
and that'll be 600 approximately
depending on the parapet depending on
the heights the last thing we want to do
is come back to our ground floor insert
below and go footings
potentially those footings depending on
what they're going to be are concrete so
172 is fine for the time being we'll
leave all of these ticked and I'll
explain what they do in an elevation
tutorial later down the track so now
let's press OK and you'll see all of
these change rapidly so all of these
have automatically changed except these
first two because they were already
renamed so let's go back rename them to
ground floor ground ceiling pressing
okay so now we have all of the same
information we had previously if I press
the command button and the up Arrow
twice you'll see in this section here
our levels change so command down goes
to ground floor command up once ground
ceiling command up once more first floor
so then I can hold my option button and
even replicate items on the trace layer
so now I'm replicating that bedroom
space I know that my stairs are going to
come up here so what I'm going to Simply
do is plan out my spaces
overall it's going to be a U-shaped
design something similar to this on the
upstairs and then we'll probably have a
small balcony here and we'll have our
major balcony on this side so if we have
one small balcony there one major
balcony over here we can select these
two Fields change their color to green
or whatever color you so choose it
doesn't really matter
like that three meters and then we have
our kitchen living dining spaces up the
top which is quite large quite generous
we can arrange this upper living as we
see fit later down the track increase
that so that's it's completely over the
garage and you don't have to introduce a
strange little roof below and then there
is a connection between our balconies
and away we go if we wanted to drag this
back increase this to have additional
living space in this corner potentially
some sort of seating reading Nook
whatever we wanted however we saw in
this space working later on we
absolutely could
so now we have our overall floor plan
kind of planned out and we'll continue
to tweak that as we move along command
down down we're going to introduce our
slabs so this is where we're going to
get into a bit more complicated and
Advanced Techniques but it is important
that we get this right
so let's go to our slab tool press
command T and open up those settings
straight away you're going to see the
slab thickness is automatically grayed
out and you can't do anything about that
because it's defined by the compositions
now the compositions are quite
self-explanatory you could have a 100
millimeter concrete structural slab with
tile finish on Top This basically
indicates to me it's 100 ml of concrete
plus 20 ml of tile and screed to create
the 120 millimeter slab and so forth
this would be a slab on ground and that
option isn't available to us at all so
what do we do well we're going to have
to create a brand new composition if we
exit out of that exit once more go to
our document go to our window tool or go
to our toolbars and select attributes
you're going to see this attributes
palette update what I'm going to do is
simply drag drop and let that place into
my toolbar so it's always there and then
what we're going to do is come to our
composition icon here selecting our
composition icon we're going to scroll
down until we see those generic slabs
which are identified by the categories
themselves we could arrange it simply
here as well so that automatically
appear at the top because we're looking
for slabs and then what we're going to
do is duplicate this so under new we're
going to select a little arrow go new
composite we're going to duplicate this
floor itself now you can continue the
naming method and go fs09 100 millimeter
concrete structural slab and it's
literally just going to be Concrete in
this case there's not going to be
anything on top I'm going to delete the
extra press ok
and then we're going to edit our skins
in the skin section you can see that we
have tiles on top we have an extra 10mm
concrete and we have a reinforced
concrete we don't need the tile we don't
need the concrete we just need the
reinforced concrete at 100 millimeters
thick so now we press ok
we go back to our slab tool we open up
the settings by going command T and
you'll see that fs09 100 millimeter
concrete slab is there which means we
can now press ok
and create a slab over top of this
existing garage
two ways to do it we can either use the
polygon or the rectangle tool simply
click drag click or we can hold the
magic wand tool hover over our 2D shape
and click on the mouse button to create
it if we come into 3D you'll see that
slab has been created on that natural
ground level where we're set and Define
so by pressing command T it is perfectly
on that reference level it's going to
continue to create this sort of error
effect wherever there's an overlap of
materials so if we go to our site
existing turn off our mesh propose press
OK you'll see that it's floating and it
is clean so if we come back in turn our
proposed mesh on it'll continue to make
this error but it's not important for
time being
coming back to our ground floor plan and
going back into our slab tool once again
command T let's say we actually want to
use a tile finish or a Timber floor
finish throughout our entire house so
we're going to select a different slab
composite we're going to Simply press Ok
We're going to use our polygonal tool
and
click around our objects now that we've
made a full shape across we can come
back into 3D lift that slab 50
millimeters so we can see it for the
purpose of this and you'll see that our
slab is basically created we have a 3D
composition of our slab very quickly
very easily now what you see is this
slab we actually created with a Timber
floor but it's not showing nor are any
of the actual layers of the slab so it's
a little bit confusing and this is where
archicad gets a little bit annoying and
a little bit challenging because not
everything is set up perfectly from the
get-go what you want to do is come down
here to the core only section and change
from core only to entire model now when
we zoom in to this actual structural
slab you'll see the structure the core
and the finishes you'll see everything
all at once the today's tutorial will be
relatively short sharp and sweet because
there isn't that much to cover with the
actual wall tool but let's get started
and actually break this down to the best
of abilities we jump back to our ground
floor plan you remember we basically set
out most of our actual room design and
our house design so what we want to
First do is come up to our wall tool the
very first top left hand corner palette
you want to click on that and then start
by pressing command T I'm going to walk
through the settings first because this
is the most critical of all of the wall
elements looking at our geometry and
positioning we're going to be able to
understand what this wall tool is and
how we're actually drawing our wall in
2D before we have to understand it in 3D
so first of all does our wall need to be
linked to anything the story settings we
set up previously will appear here and
you can either link it or not link it at
all so for me personally I'm just simply
going to link it to the first floor and
you're going to see it'll go minus 300
because our wall was previously two
seven four five if I just tap zero it
will then adjust our Wall height to 3045
which was the previous combination of
our ground floor plus all the structure
in between the two floors now now the
reason I do this is to cover any of the
claddings that can seal the floor behind
it it's just very simple manner to do it
and also at the same time if your floor
levels ever change throughout the
project you can simply adjust one
setting through the command 7 and not
have to come in and change every single
height of every single wall you can also
dictate where the wall starts from the
ground so at the moment it's starting
zero zero on the actual ground level so
I'm happy with that I'm not going to
change any of it just like slabs you
have different compositions for the
walls and the most common is your basic
composition if you select the layers
below it'll show you all of the Standard
wall types available to you in arcad now
this is the Australian select template
it has typical wall types for Australia
which means in your country these may be
significantly different for a reason
that reason being what you typically
construct in your country so for the
purpose of argument let's just select
this sp03 90 millimeter insulated stud
wall overall it's 110 millimeters 90
mils of structure and two layers of
plasterboard on either side if you
require the wall to be slanted angled
trapezoidal double slanted or any of the
above you can mess with these settings
here so for example if you want the wall
to be at a 45 degree angle you can
simply change that and it will be so for
the purpose of this regard for very
straight walls for the current time the
reference line is where you will draw
your walls so just showcase that quickly
now because it's too hard to explain
just verbally if I press OK and zoom in
down here start to draw my first wall
you'll see that the reference line is on
the outside face of our wall which up
here can be changed so if I change that
to Center the reference line or where I
click to start my wall is going to now
be in the center of the wall and so on
if I go inside face it'll be inside face
now it's a personal preference and
depends on your situation your local
codes and everything but personally I
like to go outside face and then press
the P button to make sure that it aligns
with the outside face so if I simply
finish off that wall for now the reason
I do that is if the wall composition
ever changes so let's say we go from a
90 mil to a 270 brickwork it will shift
everything inside and make the internal
smaller this usually happens very late
in the game to try and save construction
costs which means if it goes out in
Australia you have to go back to the
local authorities and get their approval
whereas when you push it in there is no
impact so that's personally why I have
my reference line to the outside face
but everybody's different every
country's regulations are different and
some people may want to rather go back
to council than mess with the interior
sizes of their spaces so let's delete
that wall press command T open it back
up to continue on where we left off as
you can see our reference line is still
set to the outside face and our offset
is zero being zero meaning that it's
using from the plasterboard not from the
structure if you wanted to go from
structure then you can actually offset
this to the size of your cladding on the
outside again this is a pretty Advanced
technique here so you don't have to
worry about it too much when you're
drawing your first house your first box
or whatever it is you're trying to
achieve this is going to be a lot more
complicated if you're overthinking it
our story settings plan View and section
are quite important as well most of the
time you only want to see your walls on
the home story but if you want to see
your walls on the story above the story
below or if you're dragging one wall
over two layers you're going to want to
simply just change this from home story
or only to all relevant stories and in
that way you will show on all flaws let
me just showcase that an example let's
draw another wall so that's our wall
right there and it's 3 meters and 45
millimeters tall if I go into 3D you'll
see it's that tall so now coming back
into ground floor pressing Ctrl up up to
go to my second floor you won't see that
wall at all because it doesn't push
through to that second floor however if
I come back into my settings let's
extend that another 4 meters higher so
it's a seven meter tall wall show it on
all relevant stories press OK double tap
up you'll see it pushing all the way
through to that Second Story similar if
I was to simply just change it to home
Story Only press OK even though it's 7
meters tall as you can see in the 3D
it's not showing up on that first floor
so that is just the documentation
question that you need to be aware of as
you're progressing throughout arcad
typically it's going to be on home story
only so you don't have to worry about it
too much the floor plan display is again
a bit more of an advanced method so it's
going to be talking about the
projections the cuts the cut symbols and
everything between I won't dive too much
into this at this point in time we might
talk about it later with doors but for
now you just basically want to be with
projected with overheads similar to show
projection we don't really need to go
into that too much if you do want to
change the overall look at the wall you
can do it in the outline section below
and also the cut fills there is no
overrides it is going to be set up as
per the composition and the material
structures just like our slab tool we
can override these surfaces make it a
different color different texture do
whatever we wish by simply activating
the override surfaces and selecting a
new color not important for the timing
so I'll just keep that as antiqued last
but not least and one of the most
critical elements of the entire arcad
process is your layers so when you're
drawing external walls make sure they
are on the external walls when you're
drawing internal on the internal and so
forth this is so critical for every
single thing that you do in arcad so
please keep looking at it keep reviewing
it and making sure your elements are on
the right layer you'll thank me later in
your iPad Journey so now let's press OK
delete that wall and simply start
drawing our new walls so let's start by
clicking on this foyer here and noticing
that our wall is going the wrong way we
still want our outside reference it's
still on the outside face why is it
facing the wrong way well icad just
works sometimes that way and all you
need to do is press the P button for
Peter to flip that wall over now you'll
also see that the wall is relatively
freely moving and you can draw it in any
angle you want you're going to want to
hold the shift button basically every
time you draw any wall that you need to
be straight otherwise your dimensioning
tools and everything in between later
down the track isn't going to work so
get into the habit of holding the shift
button to make sure that it snaps to a
15 degree increment as you're actually
drawing so for me I'm just simply going
to hold the shift button come across the
other edge of the bedroom click once and
the wall will finish now I could repeat
that step click click click all the way
around I can select that wall hold my
option button press the delete to delete
the Wall come across up to the top to
our actual geometry structure press and
hold on a little arrow and go to my
polygonal straight wall
what this will allow me to do is first
of all again holding shift click once
and simply continue drawing my wall
around rather than having to click
multiple times so in this instance I can
simply go all the way around holding my
shift button finishing off my wall and
having all of my walls drawn very
quickly now if I select one of these
walls it's highlighted as just one
element but if I press option G it'll
unsuspend my groups which means you can
automatically select all of these walls
at once this is super handy as you start
drawing more and more walls if you're
option G or alt G button doesn't work
for any reason you can look up the top
for this symbol right here which will
suspend or unsuspend your group
suspending your groups will allow you to
select individuals unsuspending you can
select them all now let's move on to
internal walls the principle is
relatively the same thing select our
wall tool open up our settings find the
wall structure we like internally it
doesn't need to be insulated so let's
just pick the sp02 feature and change
from external to internal walls pressing
ok now you'll see once again our
internal walls are not shown on this
layer simply just double click on your
ground floor over here to reset our
layer settings as we require and now
when we come back into our wall tool
you'll see all of our settings are
correct and the war internal layer is
shown now there's nothing to be really
too cautious about when creating
internal walls except that you want to
be aligning with your external walls so
as you can see here if I was to draw
this wall I want my walls to align
equally so by simply drawing it in this
fashion here these two walls are going
to align perfectly rather than this wall
being offset somewhere over here and you
having an ugly little jut or a little
defect on site so you always want to
make sure that your external walls and
your internal walls are perfectly
aligned on the inside wherever they can
be that same process is going to be
applicable over here but that is
basically the only two places is that it
applies to now just like I drew the
external walls I can simply go around
keep clicking until I'm completely
finished with my design now I like to
have a lot of my walls grouped together
wherever possible to make life easy
later on but let's say you want to
extend just this section of the wall and
not draw a separate wall in its entirety
first of all you have to unsuspend your
groups by pressing option or alt G
selecting on that wall pressing on one
of the nodes moving across to your
floating toolbar and selecting the
stretch icon make sure you hold shift
guys because you want it to be straight
that'll extend that wall all the way
across and then you can hold your option
button to find one more wall and create
a wall in that section if you so choose
now personally I don't think that that
needs a wall so I'm going to delete that
and let that foyer be its own little
thoroughfare play area now if we come
back into our 3D model you'll see a
couple things going on here first of all
we have all of our external walls
fantastic but we also have all of our
internal walls kind of showing a little
bit strange first of all they're not
really here but they are cutting it to
our floor so what the hell is going on
well first of all just like the ground
floor plan the 3D view is very critical
for your layers so if we press command L
again type in wall and turn on our
internal wall pressing OK those internal
walls will be created clicking on your
scroll wheel you can pan around by
holding shift you can orbit around as
well and the scroll wheel zooming in and
zooming out will allow you to zoom in or
out if you don't like this method of
moving around the actual project
especially when you're getting inside
the building if you look down the bottom
left hand corner you see this little man
you can click the explore little button
and then you can play arcad just like a
video game so A S D and W will move your
camera up down left right you can also
use the up down left right arrows on
your keyboard the C button will move the
camera down the space button will move
the camera up and then all you have to
do with your mouse is look around like
you were in a first person shooter video
game and then you can fly in through
your building have a little wander
around look at your hallway look at your
walls understand your spaces a little
bit better and really get a sense of
what you're designing from a human scale
so flying down to our road level we
really get an understanding of what this
building is starting to look like it's
pretty boxy it's got a little bit of a
setback going on but there's a lot more
to go for that coming back to our ground
floor plan let's simply press our option
button select one of our external walls
command up up and let's repeat those
steps for the upstairs so simply drawing
around all of the shape and then jumping
to our 3D we'll see we have our Second
Story modeled within a matter of seconds
now if you're new to arcad you're
probably also new to residential design
as a whole if you are Luis peruccio's
graphic guide to residential design is
an excellent ebook there is a link down
below but it basically showcases you all
the steps all the logic and all the
reasons why every architect around the
world makes logical and rational
decisions about their designs all the
units inside are both in metric and
Imperial to cater to the entire world
Lewis has done an amazing job and
deserves full credit on this ebook hence
why I'm sharing this resource with you
guys today so continuing the progress on
from part four where we left off without
all of our walls completed we're going
to jump down to our ground floor plan so
on the ground floor plan as you can see
it's clearly just Windows there's not
much going on whatsoever so we're going
to make it a little bit more exciting a
little bit more entertaining first of
all let's start with our door tool if we
select the door and then click on the
settings icon alternatively you can
press command T to open it up or control
T if you're on Windows we can see we
have our doors available to us we can
start by using our folder structure
which allows us to see all of the doors
available to us and above that in our
linked libraries we have empty door
openings garage doors hinge doors and so
forth we can obviously look through all
of these one by one to find the perfect
door that we're looking for
alternatively we can create some
favorites as well or last of all we can
simply search by typing in door or if
you know the door that you're
specifically looking for let's do it the
old school way let's do it the long way
just to Showcase all the parts for you
guys first of all we're going to hit
that chair icon which is your main
folder structure and embedded libraries
I personally do use the 4D library
because I find their doors and windows
significantly better but because these
come free with archicad we're not going
to dive into any paid extras we're just
going to use what is available to most
people around the world so our front
door is obviously going to be a hinge
door in this scenario it could be a
pivot it could be a sliding but let's
stick to hinge door for this if you
scroll down to find door 26 that is your
most basic door possible it is just a
typical rectangle door hinged on one
side nothing special on either side you
can see there's a million and one
options of different styles transoms
highlights Etc but we're going to use
this and we're going to move through it
one by one so let's revert back to the
very first of the drop down menu and go
through this one by one up the top what
you're going to see is very similar to
the walls and the slab it is pretty
consistent throughout icad so the width
of the door the height of the door the
seal to the story zero if you're unaware
of what the seal is if you're looking at
a door it is the Threshold at the very
bottom same for Windows the windows is
the bottom is the seal the top is the
head and the sides of the jamb they're
just technical architectural terms that
you'll get familiar with over time
they're revealed to the wall core is
basically how far in or out it pushes it
against the wall so if you're using
double brick need to close the cavity
off you need to use this setting to
adjust on the right hand side here you
have five different icons that basically
highlight what this door looks like in
different viewports so you obviously
have your plan view you have your
elevation view you have the 3D model you
have it rendered out and then you just
have some generic information about the
door itself typically I'll flick through
the first three just to understand what
it looks like so I'm planned you I know
what's showcased elevation and 3D for
the very purposes of this you don't need
to go into too much detail of
understanding all of these Dimensions
but when you do get into some technical
architectural detailing all of this will
be critically important especially
depending on the doors you actually
select because when you come to
dimensioning at the very end all of this
will be critical and if you go and
change your door style your jams your
door widths whatever all of these will
change change slightly so you want to
get familiar with this later on but not
for now if we slowly click through we
can go to our door settings and openings
so first of all door Leaf one we can
choose from a million well almost a
million 60 available styles to us from
archicad as default which is pretty much
all the doors available to us from your
local hardware store or your local door
supplier so you can select any one of
these that you like for the purpose of
this I'm going to go to HV grid just to
be able to actually articulate a few
more elements of these settings if I now
go to Elevation you'll see that's
changed completely if I wanted to add a
door handle as well to increase the 3D
appearance of this let's simply click
door handle one away we go you can
change the opening type and the frame
type as well you can also increase
natural ventilation which adds basically
a little bit of a gap at the top you
don't need to worry about natural
ventilation for the purpose of this it
is more of a construction detailing
process as you get more familiar with
arcad now we could click this little
icon here to jump ahead and adjust all
of these HP grids but I'm going to get
to that a little bit later and slowly
tap through it one by one the framer
Leaf provides you the ability to change
the actual frame itself a 27 millimeter
frame is actually quite small but I'm
not going to adjust it I'm not too
worried about it just note that you can
change the external frame here if you
wanted it so if I wanted to smash that
up to 100 you'd see a very big profile
created I'll drop that back to 27 and
continue with this
moving to Natural ventilation same as
what we ticked before you can tick it
untick it door Leaf style is where we
would have jumped ahead if we were
indoor settings so if I hit this button
it would automatically jump to Door Leaf
style which gives us a little bit more
control of the actual HP grid so for
example we can change our actual sizes
of the leaf the lower 200 I'm going to
adjust that back down to 100 just so
it's continuous all the way around the
grid width and thickness is defining
these mullions in between on the glass
so if you wanted to increase them you'd
see they jump up quite significantly and
you can change the position to either
one side or not throughout basically
means they're going to cut each
individual square of glass to the size
of these whereas if you go inside or
outside they're basically just going to
stick them on again more of a detailing
thing not too important at this point in
time now the reason I selected HB grid
is because it allows us a lot more
flexibility here so we can change this
to five we can change it to two we can
change it back four or whatever we
seriously want want it to look like
because now we have a lot more control
so if I change it to four and two I can
get quite a nice door happening moving
on to the handle settings again very
similar you can kind of adjust the
height so you can adjust the position
you can change your handle and you can
add a kickboard not too important and
continuing on again more settings that
aren't really too important at the
moment so for example if we wanted to
change that from 90 degrees opening to
45 we could change that here and the
same goes for the 3D in 3D currently it
will only be shown as completely closed
but we can open that up if we want to
the next settings are more to do again
with documentation not too much to be
worried about as a beginner we can get
back to that later on as we dive deeper
model attributes is somewhere you're
going to want to stop so if we click on
this little 3D icon you'll see outdoor
is pretty white there's not much going
on there's not much happening whatsoever
let's say we wanted to change it to a
nice black Monument door so by obviously
selecting on the side arrow and
selecting a different color it
automatically change because I have
uniform door surfaces ticked it will
automatically change everything at once
to make sure it is consistent I'm happy
with that personally I don't want to go
through everything one by one so I have
no issues with changing all the frames
to Monument in this case the leaf glass
again I'm happy to leave this clear
otherwise you can change that to frosted
mirrored satin whatever you really want
so now we can switch back to our
elevation or our floor plan view because
we know what the door is going to look
like we don't have to worry too much
further as we continue to move through
the settings we're going to get to our
reviews and our door edges this is how
it works against the actual wall itself
for the purpose of this I don't really
want to reveal I'm not too worried about
it being anything special but you can
change these for the architectural look
and feel masonry arches are a little bit
more technical but they're quite easy
you simply increase it change the style
and you'll get some sort of masonry head
on top of your window or door for me
personally I don't want to make
something else at all I'm going to keep
that unticked and move forward when we
get into fixtures and fittings this
becomes a little bit more architectural
a little bit more detailed but it gives
you a lot to actually consider and this
is what makes a door so detailed and so
important so we can we start talking
about our casing gaining thresholds sun
shades seals Etc if we were to go in and
start clicking on bits and pieces you'd
see what happens individually as we
start ticking if we were to tick the
threshold it means we're crossing over
from an internal to an external how we
want that threshold to look we can
adjust that in here and these are all
construction details that you just need
to be aware of at this time that they
exist but you don't have to worry about
it from a presentation point of view
where we get into some serious
architectural detailing of doors and
windows and you know specifically what
you're going to install this is where
you're going to be spending a little bit
of time especially if you want to seal
for example and you want all that water
to run off the bottom or you want a
little ramp or anything like that these
details are very very important and you
want to spend some time on them as you
go through however for us we're not
going to worry about any of them so
we're going to keep clicking through and
you'll see more and more options
available for each individual setting
the sun shade is something a lot of
people do use for General Aesthetics and
just like doors you have a few options
that you can choose from so if you're
building maybe a beach hut or a Beach
Shack and you want to close off those
windows where nobody's home it's a very
simple way to put some sun shades on if
you have any of those elements ticked
you will then activate the model
attributes for all of them which allows
you to change the colors very similar to
what we did for the door when we get to
the floor plan and section detailed
views personally I just hate the orange
even though it is the correct setting
and it is the right line weight and
everything I just absolutely hate it so
I tend to just simply change that to the
same line weight in Black so I don't
have to look at it continuously
if you don't want to go through changing
every single item to Black and slowly
changing bits and pieces like we just
have done there
what you can do is simply come to the
bottom overwrite the line weight select
change it to Black override the object
pen as well now everything will
automatically be changed to Black so you
don't have to actually worry about
changing individual colors if these are
ticked these you can change a million
times over and nothing will happen until
you untick these continuing along it's
providing a minimal space diagram these
are for your standards to make sure that
it actually complies with clearances so
you can adjust these to suit actual
Australian standards disability
clearances access and egress however
this is different for every single
country every single state in some
countries so you just have to recognize
this is very specific to your area tags
and labeling is something we're going to
get onto a little bit later on it is to
identify our doors and windows I
personally like to just come back and
update all the tags when already rather
than try and continuously updated as I'm
moving along because you just spend way
too much time trying to do that last but
not least you have your description and
all of your extra bits and pieces so for
instance if you want to do a bill of
quantities through archicad and you knew
this door was going to cost you two
thousand dollars to install paint
everything you could drop that figure in
there and eventually it would spit out
all of your information if you want to
you can introduce all the manufacturers
the locations details in here which is
going to spit out the information at the
very end on the door and windows
schedule but then again we'll get to
that at the very specific time when we
need to so all these description
features not too important best thing
now is you can actually press OK all
these settings are good to go you can
simply drag your door in Click once
click again and press the escape button
now if we go into 3D you'll see the door
is all black and we are missing all of
that glass and all of that detail now
you might be thinking what's going on
why is it doing that number of reasons
it is based on the actual model settings
we want to make this look fantastic so
let's open it up let's come back into
our model attributes and simply change
3D detail level from model to full and
press ok now we have all of that detail
that we originally included into that
door if we come back into our floor plan
and select our window tool this time we
can do a very very similar scenario here
all of these settings are basically
identical to what we've just gone
through in the door settings so I'm not
going to go through everyone
individually again it is just going to
be an absolute boring a waste of time
the only one that is different is your
custom corner now your custom Corner if
you tick the corner one or two it's
simply going to slice that corner
directly at a 90 degree angle by default
which means you can then connect two
corners against the side of a wall so
let's do two things first of all let's
come into our model attributes let's
change this to Black so it matches our
door now let's zoom into our bedroom
hover over one of our walls making sure
our sun icon is where the sun is coming
from so you don't want the sun to be
inside you want the sun to be on the
outside click once and then we can move
our Mouse left to right to indicate
where we want that corner so by hovering
over the left hand side you'll see that
corner column is present on the actual
right hand side where the corner needs
to be tapping Escape command or control
d i can shift that window all the way to
the corner holding my option on my alt
button
I can repeat that same process to
reintroduce another window in the corner
now if I select one of those windows
select the black hotspot I can make it
two and a half meters wide and then I
can replicate the same here so click on
the hotspot and just simply start typing
two and a half thousand press enter
coming back into 3D
you'll see we've created that corner
window right there on the edge now I
hate this corner window it doesn't look
right it doesn't fit to the actual
architecture Aesthetics so let's first
of all command T open it up double click
on these two overrides down the bottom
and change it to 21 black now we've got
black lines everywhere which is exactly
what we're looking for we're going to
jump to our sash options and change that
to a HV grid very similar to our door
two vertically and I want to have three
horizontally and then I'm simply going
to press ok now just like before we've
introduced all those additional elements
but they're not showing up
we have two options here we can go back
into our window and adjust the model
view settings or we can come down to the
bottom to our actual model view settings
where it says zero one site
if I select zero one site you'll notice
that a number of different options come
up
as you progress and slowly get more and
more detailed you adjust all of these
settings to reflect the information you
need
personally I like to see a lot of
information on very detail orientated so
let's hit construction and you'll see
all of the model settings instantly
change all elements this is a great way
to make sure you're always getting all
of the information you need so even
though we upgraded this to full
previously we weren't getting the hinged
indicators in 3D and we weren't getting
the handle and on our windows we weren't
getting these HV lines at all so now
that we've changed this to construction
we're a lot better off and we can see a
lot more if we want to make sure that
this is continuous we can simply hit the
settings button go get current settings
View and press ok so every time we go
back to 3D it's going to Showcase what
we want to see now if we come back to
the ground floor we can repeat this same
process for all the internal doors all
the extra windows and all the extra bits
and Bobs so I'll stop talking for a
minute and I'll quickly speed through
all of these internal and external doors
now if you do want this archicad file
you can jump down to the patreon down
below below sign up jump onto our
Discord chat and access every single
course part individually per arcad file
so you can cross reference your model to
what I've done
so what I've done is quickly go on
through and just added a ton of windows
and doors to our actual design on the
ground floor what I want to do is simply
start adjusting a few things now to make
them work so selecting that door let's
make it 2400 Tall select in this window
I only want it to be about 600 wide
command D allows me to move it in 3D and
I want it to be perfectly aligned next
to this door I also want to stretch out
the actual height of the window so
eating one of the hot spots stretch
vertically and dragging down allows us
to move it to a bit more of a reasonable
size I can repeat that same step align
it drag it drop it and then if I want
this window and this window to look the
same if I can hold option and then hold
option command to actually drop them and
align them then I can continue moving
all of my elements around updating my
door window sizes as I see fit and there
we go now we have all of our Windows
ready to go onto the ground floor plan
this is going to be our carport and
that's where our stairs going to be so I
haven't dragged any Windows into that
section what we want to do now is come
up to our top floor plan and actually
introduce some more creative Windows
some bifolds some louvers something a
little bit more technical a little bit
more detailed so let's jump back to our
ground floor plan command up to jump to
our top floor what I actually want to do
is drag this back into our staircase
because I don't want that pair so I'm
going to select all of these walls
option G to ungroup select my blue line
go to my offset tool and then drag that
approximately back there I can then
reduce that section A lot bigger and
increase the size of this overall space
you can actually fit something and nice
and reasonable on this side now whereas
previously you couldn't so let's focus
on these balconies as the main critical
point first of all let's say I want some
sort of little planter box here to
really give the elevation articulation
some life it's first we're going to
design a little planter box and then
we're going to design a retractable
luver screen so let's hold the option
button
copy this wall across hit P just like we
learned before let's make that about two
meters wide drag that back in although
selecting those two walls again command
T we don't want to link them at all and
we only want to make them about a meter
high coming back into 3D you'll see
we've adjusted a few bits and pieces
we've created our planter box what we
are missing is the actual first floor
slab which I haven't created on purpose
because we're going to keep adjusting
this up floor until it's just right and
then we'll add it a little bit later on
but for the purpose of this we've
created that little planter box we want
to create one more wall on this side and
we want to link it back in to this side
now you might be thinking we've just
created a big slab of wall on this side
that does absolutely nothing but that's
how we're actually going to create one
of our custom bifolding screens so let's
jump back into our door tool let's open
up our door settings let's go to Sliding
and folding doors we can either select
the bifold or the folding door whichever
one we really want for this instance I'm
probably just going to go the single by
folding door and have it all pushed to
one side now this is where it gets
creative and where we get a little bit
more technical so let's keep this HV
grid on let's directly jump to the HP
grid settings we want to drop all of
these to 50 millimeters and make it a
very thin profile ideally if we do it
out of steel we might even be able to
get away with 40 millimeters so we can
drop that quite thin next we want to
next we want to change our actual panel
grid layout vertically we don't want any
we just want to hit that to zero which
will automatically default to one
horizontally is another scenario we want
to bump that up until we are roughly
happy with the look of it so as the
doors increase they will change I've
adjusted it to appropriately where I see
fit press OK let's drag and drop this
door into the scenario and then what
we're going to need to do is actually
extend it all the way across so command
T opens it up once more
it's about four meters wide so I want to
have five doors and then I want to
probably have eight or nine horizontal
mullions nine might look a little bit
better than eight lastly we're going to
come into our model view settings we're
going to change everything to the same
color let's pick a nice wood texture so
let's go a nice horizontal Walnut and
then for the glass which is all the
individual spaces in between we just
simply want to hit air which gets rid of
everything in between now personally I
still think the width of this grid is a
little bit thin so if I bump that up to
50 maybe 40 to match the rest of it and
press ok then I can come back into 3D
and adjust the door where it needs to be
these are just simply louvers so I'm
going to increase that to 300 and I'm
going to offset that 300 from the top so
simply typing in 300 tapping the minus
button we get what we want to see and
you see these louvers are now created if
you don't want them to be opening in 3D
jump back into our settings go to
opening type and width width in 3D
simply hit zero and we have a fully
closed system now we can repeat that
same step for this side section here
because it's only two eight we don't
need as many doors we'll drop that down
to three doors press ok go back into 3D
and you'll see we have our screen
created relatively quickly now because
our doors are opening on the outside
what we're also going to be very mindful
of is a balustrade if we were to open
these doors people would fall relatively
quickly and hurt themselves so we don't
want to do that if we want to put a
balustrade in but we'll get to that a
little bit later on on this side of the
stairs we also want to replicate
something very similar but we just want
to make that a window so if we dive back
down to our bedroom grab one of these
Corner windows or even let's grab this
game's room window come to the stairs
drop that in all the way adjust it to
full length come into 3D
make sure it is the same height as our
bifold doors over here open up our
settings go to the HB grid change the
number of grids so vertically we want
one horizontally we're going to need a
few so let's go 50 maybe 40 and adjust
that width to 40 as well so overall I'm
happy with that all I need to do is
change from black to Walnut press OK and
then architecturally looking at it from
the front we have our beautiful
bifolding doors because we don't know
what we're doing upstairs just yet we're
going to come back to that in the
objects and Furniture section of this
tutorial we're going to leave that as is
we're simply going to introduce one
window here reduce the overall length of
it and last but not least go to our
doors go to our door settings open up
our sliding doors and drop an external
sliding door into our project here now
to wrap this video up we're going to
introduce one last element so let's
select this wall that was originally our
planter box let's re-link that back to
our roof plan zero zero it out press ok
go to our window tool open up our window
settings simply type in opening find a
regular square opening press OK
introduce that into our design here make
sure our seal is one meter jumping into
3D and aligning our seal height with our
window Heights over here we'll see that
we've now created an opening allowing
that lights to come through but yet
connecting our wall back to our main
house so it isn't flapping around in the
wind and we don't have the tie it across
here so today in part six we're going to
be focusing on objects and wet areas my
wet areas what I mean is the kitchen
laundry the bathroom and spaces where
typically water is running
primarily we're going to focus on the
bathroom and the laundry today to really
pinpoint exactly how you can utilize
archicad's objects and object Library
I'm going to dive into a very specific
kitchen tutorial in the next video So
today we're just focusing on these two
little spaces
to start off with we want to go into the
left hand panel here and select this
chair object that is our object tool if
we open it up by selecting the top or
command T you're going to see all of
your actual objects come up now same as
the doors and windows you can go back to
the little chair you can go to your
favorites or you can search for it by
simply typing what you want so for the
first of today we're going to go across
type in toilet and see what comes up now
what you see is ice have toilet 4D
available to me you will not this is
part of the 4D library and I prefer it
personally it is a paid accessory but
not everybody is going to have this so
we're going to stick to the actual
objects found in our CAD by default
wc26 is the default toilet and there is
so many options to go through it is
fantastic just like doors and windows
and everything along the works you have
all of your three little key icons here
the image completely rendered out in 3D
and we can go through and change change
pretty much whatever we want how do we
want this toilet to look wall hung how
do we want the system to be in wall what
do we want our button to look like we
can go through a number of different
scenarios with the toilet now this stuff
is relatively boring so I will not go
through it in immense detail because
there's no point most of the settings
are exactly the same as the doors and
windows and walls that we've talked
about so far they're just different
categories specific to the object every
single object you click on is going to
have a different format of settings in
it but it's all going to be relatively
consistent and you're going to be able
to work your way through it quite easily
two things to pay attention to is show
in 3D is if you want the system to be
shown and the actual object layer it's
on so for example it is on the wrong
layer for me personally you want MEP
Plumbing you want to press OK and then
when you click it's going to tell you
that this layer is hidden and what do
you want to do with it so personally I
just want to show it and see that toilet
now for me when I'm designing wet areas
or anything really I like to get all of
the objects out and ready to go so if we
move our toilet across the side command
D hit that option button holding shift
to make sure it's straight command T
opens up our settings I can start
utilizing the next object I need in that
wet area so let's type in shower and see
what we get again freeform multi shout
4D are basic 4D Library objects which
we're not going to be using which can be
used as standard shower cabin from
archicad I'm not going to go in and
change too many objects I'm just going
to create it for now and continue on the
last thing that I want inside this small
little bathroom is a vanity Basin now
archead has a series of different styles
types basins cabinets and the works the
arcad 26 upgrade got a quite a decent
upgrade for the cabin tree so if you
want to just simply use the cabinet
you're most welcome to it is a great
little object so pressing OK you'll see
that we have three objects created here
we have a toilet a shower and a hand
Basin in a small space like this if I
press the M for measure you'll see that
it's 2.4 by 2.4 roughly internally now
that isn't a huge space but it does give
us plenty of space to do something with
so let's select our vanity Basin object
press command e for elephant which will
open up our rotate tool click in the
center hold shift let go of shift go all
the way up to 90 degrees whilst holding
shift to snap and finish clicking we'll
just simply going to rotate our vanity
Basin across now if I press command D to
help me move that vanity across I can
move my vanity directly in front of my
door so that when I walk into my
bathroom I'm not seeing a toilet I'm not
seeing a shower I'm directly engaging
with what I need the most now we're
going to select our shower command e
repeat that same step command D to move
it along place it next to that vanity
Basin simply measure from there to our
wall and we'll see it's 900 wide
personally I'd like a meter so I'm going
to press command D move this up 100 Mil
select on my vanity Basin increase that
from 900 to a meter and then reposition
it perfectly across now you might be
thinking what the hell am I doing what's
the plan here well actually what I
really want to do is decrease the size
of this laundry increase the sizes
bathroom and get a little separate
toilet going because I don't personally
like to have a toilet free and open so
when I'm going to do is Select this wall
drag it down place it hard up against
our shower and then go command D press
the option button to duplicate that and
simply type in 1200. now you'll see I've
created a new wall and a new room to
allocate space for this toilet The Fill
is now no longer appropriate and no
longer accurate so I'm going to select
my laundry and my bathroom and just
press delete I'm also going to move my
title of laundry up a little bit and I'm
going to select my door command D move
that up a little bit as well now to make
sure I have enough room in my laundry I
particularly want about 1600 so looking
up I have 1670 I'm happy with that
amount of space in my laundry I can
select these two walls command iron like
we've learned before
select my toilet command e rotate select
command D move it into place now
obviously we're going to need another
door so option
drag drop select that door and drop it
in if you haven't noticed we're
progressing a lot more in this tutorial
we're getting quicker we're getting
faster we're able to do things a lot
easier so hence why I'm not slowing it
down I'm not babying it for you guys
anymore you've learned a few skills
you've learned a few features and we
know what to do as I'm doing this live
in front of you
now if we go to our 3D view click our
little man down the bottom we can
explore our video by playing it like a
video game so let's continue to fly
through our internal space let's go into
our bathroom we'll see that our site is
clashing with our floor so command L to
open up our lasers type in site I'm
simply just going to hide the site
itself so we can see our floor very very
well you'll see that the Cabinetry is in
the window is clashing with our wall and
with our shower and our toilet is also
clashing with that window
so what we want to do is now we want to
come back to our ground floor plan we
want to readjust our window so we want
to align it to that space I personally
would also like to increase the size of
this shower let's go from 800 to 1500
and then move this door across so now
it's a nice large shower that you can
actually access from the side but
there's still a few little details
missing so first of all
let's just duplicate the shower command
T to change it and let's type in towel
because we're missing our towel rail so
by default you'll have a towel rail
style in archicad that you can select
from single bar for the purpose of this
is perfectly fine again I hate those
colors I really don't like them
personally so I'm just going to change
that to a black press ok
rotate it around and drop my towel rail
in on the side next to this hand Basin
now it's up to you guys where you want
the towel rail it could go next to the
hand Basin or you could rotate it once
again put it next to the toilet door so
it's directly in front of your actual
shower just depends where you want it
just like the handrail you also need a
toilet roll holder so if you type in the
toilet you'll get toilet paper dispenser
you can simply go wall mounted and
rotate that in drag drop it next to your
toilet coming back to our 3D images
you'll see that our window is still a
little bit too low so let's increase
that window seal height from 1800 to
2200 which will now sit clear above our
shower and it'll be nice and quiet in
this space you'll see that the the tower
rail is way too low so let's lift that
up to 900.
and fly away into our bathroom the
spaces are coming along very quickly
very easily and exactly as we want them
to look now you might be thinking it's
very challenging to fly around those
spaces and I don't really want to be
flying through walls all the time if
that's what you're thinking select this
Marquee tool and because we just want to
showcase this ground floor not
everything on all floors make sure
you've got the thin Marquee tool not the
thick Marky tool then what you want to
do is simply just cut off one wall two
walls or have many walls you don't want
to see right click show Marquee in 3D
and there you go we'll just show that
space that we've marked in 3D cut
everything open so we can actually see
what's going on this is a great way to
quickly see any space deep inside the
house and isolate individual elements
for example this way we can select our
Cabinetry and go no this is hideous I
don't like the tap style let's change it
to this font I don't like countertop
Edge let's change it here I don't like
sync let's make it a rectangle I want
the tap to be wall mounted I'd prefer
this style over the other one I want the
tap to be brass instead of metal you
have the freedom to quickly change
things go okay view it in 3D continue
adjusting and changing so let's say I
still don't like any of these elements I
can go through let's change our door
styles maybe I want to draw instead of
doors I can simply click on that let's
say I want the Cabinetry to be black I
want my door handles to be brass to
match the tap wear we want to cat tone
to be white marble pressing okay we see
a massive change in our actual
architectural style A visual
representation and we can continue to
play with the interior design as we see
fit so obviously if we come back to our
ground floor plan now that's the
bathroom pretty much done it doesn't
take very long to drag and drop objects
in its archicad
but now let's come across to our laundry
a laundry might need to be a little bit
more detailed a little bit more
intricate so what do we do same kind of
system let's go into our object tool and
let's start by typing in laundry to see
what objects pop up because I have the
4D Library again there's a few more
objects that you won't see for you for
example I have a full laundry detailed
documented away you go you can simply
click OK drag and drop it into that
space in a matter of seconds and adjust
it how you see fit however you guys
won't have this available to you so
we're going to go through one by one and
showcase individual items let's pick our
washing machine Let's Go a front loader
press OK drag and drop that washing
machine into the corner duplicate it
across command T let's get our dryer
same sort of deal open it up we have our
dryer we have our washing machine now
let's go into our little chair icon to
view everything we have available to us
scroll Down's kitchen cabinetry and
start utilizing some of these elements
now the kitchen cabinetry is pretty
basic we don't need too much and it
really depends what you want your
laundry to look like so for the purpose
of this let's just grab a base block
cabinet and I'm happy to have all
drawers for for the sake of argument I
do want to change this from Plumbing to
Furniture fixed press OK drag that into
the correct position and then what we
can do is simply drag drop duplicate a
number of these items across until we're
happy with the size if you have a little
bit of a awkward space left over you can
simply hit one of the hot spots hold
shift
extend it out all the way so that that
space is perfect for your requirements
now once again let's grab our Marquee
tool right click show Marquee in 3D and
let's have a quick look at our laundry
so laundry is relatively basic there's
not too much going on we probably want
to put a little bit more effort into
this if we were designing these spaces
rather than just dragging and dropping
objects in but let's say we don't like
this cupboard here command T let's grab
a standing cupboard we can adjust that
height to whatever we see fit so let's
say we want to drop it to the top of
this window and that's where we're going
to introduce a bulkhead next we might
not like that cupboard we might want to
go through our settings it might need a
sink or a trough and then you can adjust
what kind of sink you need pressing OK
we now have a sink in our laundry most
likely that sync would probably be a lot
closer
to our washing machine so we'd simply
drag that one across there move our sink
into the other position and then
increase our Cabinetry to match the Gap
coming back into our 2D floor plan
you'll see our laundry is pretty much
done if we wanted to add more we could
right click rotate drag and drop a
couple of these spaces in here add some
shelving decrease the depth of that only
300 and then we could Marquee our space
once again and for those who had some
extra wide cupboards here so instead of
just dragging that full width we'll
probably split it in half duplicate it
and then we have two large cupboards for
additional storage as we need and our
objects for the wet areas are very much
done now because there's no point going
into the bedrooms into another tutorial
I'm simply going to show you guys now
find a bed that you're relatively happy
with let's select this bed 26 because
it's got the bedside table we spent
everything change our color change it to
30 loofs press OK press OK and then
rotate our beds wherever we need them so
we can drag and drop them in see what
we're looking at and our beds are
underneath that corner window tucked in
to this space over here
we can duplicate once more on the other
bedroom wall rotate it around same thing
for the game's room grab a bed command T
open it up let's type in pool we've got
a pool table available to us and press
OK drag and drop a pool table into the
middle of the room
and maybe we have two pool tables for
some strange reason but just like that
object is so easy to drag and drop into
space and all you have to do really is
search through your available library
and find whatever it is you're looking
for so last week we wrapped up with the
ground floor making sure that our wet
areas were all well detailed as well as
few bedrooms and our game Drew today
we're moving upstairs to the Grand
spaces the kitchen living and dining
areas now obviously to be respectful to
Lewis I'm not going to be showing you
what's inside these ebook I'm simply
going to be using what is available to
him on his Instagram page free of charge
if you want to grab his ebook just
simply go to the description and grab a
copy for yourselves today but I can show
you some great information here even
some amazing kitchen shaped designs and
circulation spaces for living all little
minor things both in the metric and
Imperial so that we are constantly
reminded of good design even when we
struggling to figure out the best
practice so after that let's dive back
into arcchad and start figuring out our
spaces first of all there's quite a lot
of things happening up here and we
probably want to actually make a master
bedroom or some sort of Master Suite up
here so let's hold the option button
select one of the walls below
and simply just draw one line all the
way through and we can pretend that this
right hand side of our entire Suite is
going to be our Master Suite this L
shape at the top can remain as our
kitchen living and dining now for the
purpose of this I would kind of Envision
that the kitchen would either be
somewhere along this back corner here or
completely concealed behind the stairs
on this side now this is a design option
A Design Choice again not really
focusing on design in this course and
also just about understanding icad as
best as we can so let's start by
incorporating just some basic Furniture
so we'll go to our object tool open up
our object and let's use the dining
Suite again I don't really love the
green we can change the colors to
whatever we like pressing OK let's just
drop a dining room table in for now if
we select one of the pink hotspots on
the outside of the table it's going to
let us adjust the table itself so let's
jump across the Lewis's amazing page on
Instagram and see what he says about
table sizes so here's a great example of
dining table sizes on Instagram that he
dictates how big a table should be let's
say we want an eight person table for
one example he's telling us it needs to
be 244 by
107. let's come back in hit one of these
hot spots 2440 press OK double check his
Dimensions because my memory is terrible
as I'm talking and then tap
107 oh and okay now you can see we have
a beautiful eight person dining table
all of our chairs are pushed out if we
click one of the pink hot spots on the
chairs we can push them in a little bit
to make it appear exactly as we want it
to so now we have a beautiful table
let's duplicate that across like we've
learned before open up our settings and
and type in sofa straight away we have
our sofa Lounge Suite available to us as
a favorite in archicad which basically
showcases a full round set now Lewis
dictates living room Rug sizes in this
image for a very particular purpose I've
read through this ebook I use it quite
often now because it is a great reminder
and hence why I'm sharing this resource
with you guys today the 2.7 by 3.7 rug
size you see in this picture is
something that's quite critical to
understand basically you don't really
want more the 2.7 meter Circle between
all of these chairs because you're not
going to be able to hear people
conversing And discussing topics of
conversation very easily so if we were
to plant a 2.7 by 3.7 meter rug
underneath our Lounge Suite back in art
CAD we can do that either in 3D or as a
simple 2D diagrammatic expression for
the purpose of this I don't really want
to go too far so I'm just going to
Simply come across the film tool over
here make sure it's on my right layer as
always change my geometric method to
rectangular I can select one of my
drafting fills so this is going to allow
me to have a lot more options than any
of these which we'll get into later and
then I'm just going to Simply select 25
I'm happy with it being 25 transparent I
don't need it to be 50 75 or anything
else and I don't need any patterns so
solid color 25 fitting my pen color as
the background solid fill but just pick
a gray and then we don't want anything
in the background we want it to be
transparent now we can click once type
in 2 7 type in 3 7 and we'll have our
two seven by three seven rug rotating it
accordingly and moving it underneath our
actual Lounge Suite coming back to this
image from Lewis you'll see that the
chairs and the sofa are sitting about
halfway past the rug which means we have
the freedom to actually extend this out
quite a lot so if we open up our
settings for this table and chair you
can see how much space we have how much
width we've got the way we get around
increasing It Is by actually increasing
the space between each couch so this
couch has about 200 clear maybe we want
400 maybe we want a little bit more
let's type 400 push our chairs out ever
so slightly move Center and we can
probably adjust that 450 and will be
perfectly aligned so now we have this
beautiful space 2.7 by 3.7 meter rug
underneath very easy distances so if you
imagine from the center of this chair to
the center of this sofa it's 2.4 and
from the center over here to 2.1 even
worse case scenario talking across the
table which we really really don't want
to be doing is 3.5 so personally
speaking this is not a good conversation
point the person on the right and the
person on the left would not be able to
manage a conversation without disturbing
a a conversation happening across these
two chairs so just something to be
mindful of if you're picking a space of
this size and this caliber now let's
simply pick up our living room set drag
and drop it down there redo the same
thing with our actual table and now we
can understand that we actually have
quite a lot of space this house is
absolutely huge now yes we could turn
this into a theater room or another
bedroom or do whatever we like or we can
really create a massive kitchen with a
pantry a walk-in scullery all sorts of
bits and pieces completely up to you
guys completely up to the architectural
expression that you're trying to achieve
so first of all you have a number of
different kitchen shapes and styles all
of them have different forms functions
and purposes but you'll notice that all
of them are articulating a triangle
pattern if I take a screenshot of this
and overlay a quick diagram and you'll
see it doesn't matter which actual
kitchen style we pick we're always
working in that triangle manner except
along the long wall obviously because it
can't be done personally I really like a
gallery kitchen or an island kitchen so
we're going to be starting with
something like this we're probably going
to be using an island kitchen combined
with a gallery kitchen to create
something a little bit different a
little bit special so let's start
working on that first of all what you
want to do is create your slab tool you
want to make sure the slab is no longer
on the slab General but on the fixed
Furniture layer you want to change it to
a rectangle and you want to go command T
to open up the settings now you could
redefine an actual slab composition or
you could simply change the actual
building material to Stone or whatever
you like change that from 120 mil to 40
mil which is the average thickness of a
bench top if it's porcelain's about 12
if it's engineered stoned probably about
20 and you can have all sorts of choices
while you're here you can immediately
change that to a different color let's
go White marble and press bouquet now
like I said we have a ton of room and we
want to utilize as much of this as
possible so let's start by using this
back wall here and that's a six and a
half for metal Island bench which is
absolutely huge it does not need to be
that big nobody needs another adventure
that big so first of all what we're
going to do is start typing in 1 500
minus so it offsets that wall 1500 from
where I've drawn an imaginary wall below
and then I want to make it at least in
600 millimeters we go back to Lewis's
page he will tell you generic clearances
around kitchens bench tops and bits and
pieces he will also tell you the average
width of a kitchen island bench now
obviously metric and Imperial don't
convert perfectly across and the codes
and regulations in every country and
every state are different so you have to
be mindful about this graphic guide it
is simply a guide for instance he's
telling us that it's 24 inches deep or
61 centimeters in Australia the typical
kitchen island bench is 600 deep or 650
depending on the edging you have now I'm
talking millimeters 600 millimeters
which is 60 centimeters or 65
centimeters which is 650 millimeters
whereas the island is about 900. so
these measurements and conversions
changeovers aren't exactly perfect but
they're a great starting point and a
great guide for everybody I'm happy with
the benchtop being that far across the
back and then I want to duplicate this
bench top in line with the existing one
what I'll then do is move it I
personally like to move at 1550
millimeters because we have the row and
then I also want to adjust the edge of
this 1550.
now the reason I use 1550 is because
this is an Australian disability
compliant standard it allows two people
to walk through it allows anybody in a
wheelchair to move around quite freely
and if you have the space it's highly
recommended if you don't have the space
bring it back into about 1200 1250 and
you'll be happy as well anything under
that is a little bit tight a little bit
claustrophobic and probably more a
one-person kitchen we then want to grab
one of these edges and extend it out 300
millimeters to create our Island bench
so as you can see our kitchen is
starting to take shape we have our back
bench cross here we have our Island
bench here and we have a ton of space on
the left hand side you might be thinking
what are we going to do with all of this
space well I actually want to create
something magical and something special
at the back here almost like a Chef's
Kitchen first of all what I'm going to
do is simply highlight that kitchen
bench top drag and drop to start
creating a new little zone now this zone
is simply going to be 600 wide and 1550
short off that side and I'm also going
to make it 1550 short off this side so
now we've created a little Island Middle
so when anybody needs to access this
space they can access it from both sides
if we wanted to close off this side with
some sort of pantry or Cabinetry or even
some storage for cups and plates
displays whatever we could and then we
could only access from one side but for
this I'm going to create this as a Zone
this is going to be my fridge and my
oven Zone which will get back to in a
second what we then want to do is
basically create our pantry in the back
space so if we come to our object tool
open up our object settings type in
linen you'll get your basic linen
Cabinetry now I use Linen cavatry in
this one because it's got a number of
shelves and that's what typical pantries
have as well so it's a great little
object to use for the purpose of this
this lady to bore you with this sort of
stuff so I'm simply going to drag and
drop it in and adjust it to create a
little space okay so now what I've done
is quickly imported few little walls a
couple doors and re-adjusted my shelving
what I have is two lc8 shelves on the
rear wall two eye shaped shelves in the
middle so you basically create a full
walk-in Pantry it is a massive you could
last months and months and months in
this Pantry an overkill for a three
bedroom house but again not really a
design tutorial it is just simply
throwing ideas out there and getting
things to work we have our huge kitchen
on this side and what I've actually done
is incorrect there I need that Cabinetry
so the wall is on the back side as I
continue to think about it I do
personally believe that it would be
better to close off that side close off
that side and redefine these spaces as
maybe something a little bit more simple
a little bit more practical so now what
we have idea of shapes Gallery in the
back a full walk around Pantry just like
we had before again complete Overkill
way too big and fridges and phrases here
so what we now need to do is simply drop
in a few items let's copy this table
across let's type in sync and see what
we have available to us we'll search our
full active library and I'll try to not
pick a 4D sync for you guys typically
I'd pick something like this because
it's very common in Australia it is a
great sync but let's go sync general
purpose 26 let's use style 14 is
phenomenal let's simply drop in a tap
press OK rotate that to where we want it
and let's say we want to put the sync
over here is one we want another copy
over here in the scullery so let's drop
a secondary sync down here in this
gallery now we want to copy paste that
across once again let's type in oven now
like I said we do want an oven we
probably want something like an oven
stack Cabinetry you can download that
from graphisoft and embed it ideally I'd
use the 4D stack but the purpose of this
let's download embed press ok to drop
that one in right rotate it around and
let's say we want two oven Stacks the
third we want to be our fridge I'll
simply grab this stainless side by side
double door fridge and import it into
arcad press OK relocate it to where we
need it to be type in cabinet see what
we have available to us we probably want
a tall standing cabinet so that stacked
cabinet will be great drag and drop it
in once again and let's just duplicate
it a couple of times extend that one
larger to leave our slab below if I
quickly come into 3D see that obviously
we have no slab between our floors so
first of all let's jump back to our
first floor press command down right
click on our first floor show wish Trace
come to slab change our slab structure
so we want it to be something a little
bit thicker let's go 300 mil suspended
Timber floor and let's just change that
to
Timber Timber Pines fine make sure it's
on the right layer and Trace around the
perimeter as we've done before so now
when we come back into 3D you'll see
that slab has appeared it's on it's not
positioned correctly so drag it up
simply take a quick look at what's going
on our slabs are way too low so we
select our slabs let's lift them up 900
mL
and you can see we've got a kitchen
starting we've got the bench tops sinks
we've got our pantry in the rear our
scullery and we can continue to add
little bits and pieces so we could go
back in add cabinets underneath the
island bench and cabinets across here
and overhead cupboards introduce one or
two or even three more windows in the
background and we would be able to call
this a day and there we are drag dropped
a few more little cabbage a few more
little pantries Slover head cupboards
dropped in three Windows across the back
a little splashback window in the center
as well and we've created most of our
kitchen living dining space obviously we
need to drag in our stairs as well as
well as create our Master ensuite so
what I'll do is I'll create this master
ensuite ahead of time available to you
guys to download through the patreon
link down below patreon you can grab it
through the Discord chat all of these
pln files are available through patreon
and through Discord so if if you want to
grab the Palin with the master suite
completely finished you can grab it
otherwise you'll see the design in the
next tutorial moving on to part 8 which
is our roof design you'll notice that I
went ahead and created this master suite
on the right from part 7 just like we
discussed if you want to copy it take a
screenshot go ahead go for it but let's
move on to the actual roof if we jump
across the 3D we'll see the roof has
nothing going on it's pretty basic it's
pretty boring nothing special whatsoever
but we do want to make it something
special we do want to make it something
exciting so how do we do that well first
of all let's discuss what the actual
roof styles are and the roof types are
so let's jump back to the first floor go
to our roof tool over here on the left
hand panel
it simply looks like an A-frame roof
select our roof tool make sure it's on
the right layer as always and then we
have two options we have a single plane
and we have a multi-plane roof option
the multiplane is going to create a
typical and traditional hip and Valley
roof I'm going to start with this one
because we're not actually going to use
it I don't like them too much they're
great in particular use cases but not
for this design today
so to create a traditional hip and
Valley roof you simply select one of the
corners on the outside making sure that
your reference line which is the first
line of this selection is correct that
depends on your wall structure your roof
type if it's steel or Timber how you're
pitching it Etc but for the purposes of
today we are literally just going to
trace around the outside of our building
perimeter if I finish that box you're
going to see it immediately creates this
hip and Valley roof so I'm going to
bring that to the front to Showcase it
in front of all of my furniture you'll
see there are a number of parts to this
roof as it stands but I know it's on the
wrong layer straight away so I'm going
to click command T changing from my
first floor to my roof plan and press OK
Now command up you'll see it on the
floor above command down you will see it
disappear if I come into my 3D once
again you'll see that roof created and
it is looking pretty good pretty quickly
it's not too shabby it's pretty basic
but it does the job and if you've never
used a human value roof you probably
have no idea what any of these parts
caught I'm going to jump back to our
dear friend Louis farusio and just
showcase one of his great pictures from
his ebook which explains quite a few of
the elements straight away so if we look
at this pictures here you'll see that
the gutters are the elements around the
perimeter of the roof that capture the
water they are always well most
typically the lowest point of the roof
and that section
so in our instance the gutter would be
positioned right here if we were to
create a roof now graphisoft has CI
tools built in so you can go coverings
roof coverings and select a corrugated
roof very quickly press OK and it will
create a 3D corrugated roof now this
roof again is a paid extension paid
add-on to arcad you may or may not have
it but that's simply you see the gutter
created at the bottom if you don't have
it not a problem we're not really going
to be talking about the 3D cladding too
much I'm simply going to undo that step
and keep going talking about the highest
point in the roof line of the hip and
Valley roof is the ridge now the ridge
is this line at the very top it's also
this line at the very top the ridge is
again the uppermost like a Ridgeview
Mountain once again talking about those
hips and those valleys and those
mountains the valley itself is the part
of the roof that falls in between two
sections towards a guard
so this section right here would be our
Valley in the roof and you would have a
valley gutter technically inside that
falling into your downpipes and together
along the perimeter the opposite of the
valley is obviously the hit the hips and
the valleys and in our case the hips are
right here they're like the hips of a
person they point up towards the middle
of the spine so you can almost see a
small person here if you draw a really
funny picture so for me personally just
because this is how my brain works you
would see
a person's legs here you would see their
body here there's one arm there's
potentially another one over there and
there's a random head so we have our
funny man from our hip and Valley roof
alongside all of these elements of
course you're gonna have extra things
like Dormers and skylights ridges and
bits and pieces here and there but
typically that is most of the
information you need to know about a hip
and Valley roof if I was to put back the
4D cladding you'd see a few extra items
as well first of all you'd see the hip
flashing which covers the two cladding
elements on the each side you see the
ridge flashing and you would also see
the valley gutter now that corrugated
tin comes all the way across that
baligata sits underneath the corrugated
tin so the water doesn't circulate and
the pressure isn't built up pushed back
in cause water problems so the water
naturally falls down the ribs of the
corrugated into the valley gutter into
our gutters on the side and then you
would have the down pipe connected as
well now there's no down pipes drawn on
this for whatever particular reason at
the moment if I go back to my first
floor plan command up I can simply
create a quick gutter just to Showcase
it to you guys here that right there is
our downpipe from our gutter now and if
you've never seen a downpipe in a gut up
what it does is basically control the
flow of water off the roof into the
ground and away from the house it is
critical that you do not let the water
simply just stop right here next to the
foundations of the house because those
foundations will over time fall away the
ground will Decay and the house will
collapse so be smart with your water get
the plumber to Route the water away
correctly into soaked Wells and just get
that water away from the foundations of
your house once again this cladding not
important so let's simply select it all
delete it and move away I don't think
I've actually spoken about this find and
select tool so let's undo that and
showcase that once again for you guys if
you press command or control F you can
activate the find and select tool if you
can't find it there help find and select
it's also in your edit menu down the
bottom there to use the find and select
tool you can either go through one by
one select individual item you want add
additional information and filtering
tools such as surface color or even the
surface name or anything you want in
between but simply you select one item
you ask it to select the properties it
finds all those properties and then you
can select everything similar you can be
as specific as you want with this or
very generic just to get rid of all roof
coverings in this instance what we've
done now is basically explained a hip
and Valley roof very very quickly and we
can delete it because we don't want it
we don't need it it's ugly if we move
back down to our first floor plan just
so we can see what's going on select our
roof tool again and select the infamous
single pane roof this thing is a pain
because you're going to have to redraw
and reconnect every single section of a
roof if you do a hip and Valley roof
this way if you're doing a skillion roof
a mono pitch roof a shed roof whatever
you call it around the world this is the
way you do it simply select that single
plane select the lowest point of your
roof which for me will be this back side
put it on the side you want the roof to
go up and then start by drawing your
roof for me in this instance I want all
of the walls on the outside to be
parapets and I'll explain what that
means in a second
so what I'm going to have to do is draw
on the inside of my external walls this
time except for the very bottom one
where my gut is going to be so drawing
on the inside of every single one
connecting finishing off
coming back to our 3D we'll see our roof
again on the wrong level so change that
to roof plan press OK and it's at a 22
degree pitch doesn't need to be at 22
degrees depending on where you are in
the world depending on how much rainfall
you get depending on what if you get
snow or not you can basically go down to
as low as one degree which is one degree
and nine minutes if you're documenting
to Timber framing codes now a single
pitch roof is super basic it pitches
from the back side it goes in One
Direction all the water falls in One
Direction and you have downpipes only on
one side and one gutter on one side
the disadvantage is you basically need
to select all of your external walls
increase the overall height of these
walls which increases the budget at
least 150 millimeters past the cladding
now this is just the roof structure not
the cladding so I'd probably go anywhere
from about 300 mil plus this which means
our Wall height is 3 900 millimeters
I can easily just connect this as well
by duplicating that wall hiding it and
creating that little box but there we
have a skillion roof where you basically
don't see the roof whatsoever it is
completely concealed and if we were to
once again go to our CLI tools coverings
root coverings again paid feature you
may or may not have this
it will create our roof what we didn't
discuss in the hip and Valley roof is
what the sides here are called and if I
select my roof go to my coverings and
edit my edges it'll allow me to explain
that a little bit better so this one is
backwards Upside Down based on the image
I'm showing you the gutter this line
here is actually the bottom side where
our gutter is visible this on the side
has created a barge a junction a barge
and another Junction there's a few
different options including an apron in
this particular scenario every one of
these walls except the bottom wall here
where the gutter is would be an apron so
we would change
all of our roof types from barge and
Junction to apron and press OK you'll
see the cladding style immediately
changes and the flashing type changes
you're basically cut into the side of
this silicon join or run that flashing
all the way up over and cap the top of
this wall to protect it from the weather
if you didn't want to extend past this
wall so for instance you wanted the roof
to extend past and so you could see the
side of that actual roof profile first
of all you'd have to trim the roof so to
do so right click our Wall come down to
connect solid element operations the
wall is our Target the roof is our
operator and in this instance we want to
subtract with an upwards Extrusion smash
that execute button and you'll see that
wall is automatically trimmed now we
would have to change our roof Edge once
again here from an apron double click on
that which will barge press ok to see
that change to a barge the barge very
simple it is the side like a barge board
at the Docks where the boats come and
plow and hit that is the exposed element
to the side of the roof just to protect
the side of the roof from everything at
a junction obviously quite simple if
there was another route falling back
that way it's a junction point where
these two elements meet so I'm not going
to really go ahead and show that but
that is very simply put all of the
elements of the roof how they operate
how quickly they're formed together and
what they need to be how they need to
operate if you wanted this roof to be a
low pitch a higher pitch or anything in
between you could now if you wanted a
concrete roof whole another kettle of
fish first of all you don't have any
cladding on top you have a flat roof
zero zero this concrete roof would then
literally be defined lined by four was
in the material itself like there is in
your bathrooms and your showers Falling
Towards different waste points in the
roof this roof would then drain either
through the building wherever possible
or it would still drain to the edge
around a box gutter which is basically a
gutter surrounded by parapets concrete
roofs are great in the right environment
if it's in snow you've got a heating so
that the snow doesn't overload the roof
and collapse in on you and if you're a
torrential rain it isn't recommended
because you may end up with problems as
well however
besides the actual price of concrete
roofs in Australia they are awesome they
look phenomenal if you wanted to extend
them five six seven meters or past you
easily could if you wanted to cancel
either something like that create a
beautiful shading device over the side
of your house with no supporting
structure underneath you could you can't
really do that in too many other
elements unless you get massive steel
columns whereas that could probably be
350 400 ml thick of concrete
cantilevered backspan away you go but if
you did want a concrete roof you can
then extend your roof to the outside
trim all of your walls to the top of
that roof and Away you go to progress
this tutorial it's part nine where we
start looking at elevations and sections
I'm going to leave this roof as an
entire apron around all the sides so
simply undo a few of those features and
then I'm going to delete my c i color
Rings tool roof because I know not all
of you will have it we need to make this
thing absolutely stunning and we're
going to do that both in 2D and in 3D so
let's start by jumping up to our floor
plan and moving up to our Upper Floor I
think there's just subtle ways we can
really manipulate this and make it even
better so let's start by grabbing this
external wall moving at about a meter
connecting it with our other external
wall and just simply reconnecting these
Corners jumping back into 3D we'll see
straight away pushing it out gives us a
little bit of a cantilever over this
floor Edge and makes it just stand out
that little bit more our slab in the
middle is for whatever reason the wrong
color and so is most of our building if
I'm being honest what I want to do is
select all of my external walls command
T open them up change my material to
some sort of white let's go to Titanium
white which is absolutely fine for now
this allows us also to change the slab
Edge to Titanium White so if I press OK
find all the walls that weren't selected
previously make sure they go white as
well we're starting off with a pretty
basic White House next we want to extend
our slab all the way across to the edge
of the balcony align it with our
external walls and then add a little bit
more to this design because at the
moment it's pretty basic it's pretty
boring so what we created up here before
was a little planter so what we need to
do here is go to our mesh tool and
introduce a little bit of fill or Earth
so if I change that across change it to
Earth Brown
we can see now that's a perfect little
planter for either some cascading plants
a little tree or anything in between we
don't have too much room left on our
site but we want to maximize the width
to make this thing look really really
wide so we'll come back to our ground
floor plan right click show us Trace
reference for our site plan we can see
how far across we can go so if we use
one of these walls extend it all the way
to the boundary come back to our 3D
we'll see we've created something quite
large we then want to copy that wall
directly to our ground floor plan as
well this is going to allow us to make
this building look bigger than it
actually is
so how wide do we want to make it well
personally I probably want to make it
about as wide as this window to really
allow maximum width here we can
introduce a nice cascading green wall to
really give this house some punch
looking from the straight A beautiful
white black green design is going to be
simply stunning and it's going to stop
everybody in their tracks
what we do need to do is actually give
this wall some stability though because
that will never stand the test of time
if we also do that on the Upper Floor
Plan you'll see we've boxed it out a
little bit given it some actual strength
and stability but also faked most of it
because that there is just an
architectural feature personally I don't
like this window right here so what I
want to do is actually extend it up a
little bit and then break this elevation
some more so what I'm going to do is
push this wall back another 500
millimeters reduce the earth I created
and cut that slab out now we've given
this some definition some bulk some
articulation and we've broken it up a
little bit it is very very bulky still
even at this stage and it is still a
little bit squished but there are
constrictions on this site so we're just
going to leave it as it is coming back
to our first floor plan I want to
introduce a louvreed system over this
garage so let's go into our object let's
type in shade and just use a simple
solar shade if we change those pen tools
like we previously discussed change a
layer to root structure let's just go
roof covering for this one drop it into
our garage and manipulate it so it fits
the way we want it to if we come back
into 3D we see what we've created is a
Louvre over our carport but we want to
give it some more louvers it's way way
too open and not actually what it'd be
like when it's constructed so let's
change these figures from four to maybe
25 that way we have a ton of louvers
available to us we also want to change
this to Wood so it matches our Louvre
screens finally we're going to need to
introduce a column as well we haven't
talked about columns too much but if we
drop a column in by simply using the
same settings that are by default go
into 3D see where it landed on the wrong
floor straight away let's drop that to
the ground floor press ok
we can extend the column similar to how
we've done everything in the past go
through these settings change the size
of the column to what we want it to be
so let's say we want to be 100 change
the material to Wood change the
structure we want it to be some sort of
Timber structural column press ok so
what next how can we further this design
how can we make it even better well at
the moment it's pretty boxy it's pretty
basic it's still pretty boring this wall
I still believe needs to come even
further so let's push that out another
500 mil just to really continue to give
this house a bit more Grandeur in the
overall design extend everything to suit
this new parameter and there we go we're
starting to get a bit more Grandeur in
this house we're starting to make it
look and feel like it's worth investing
in our time and our services
as part of elevation design you
obviously want to do this in 2D or 3D
whatever you're most comfortable with
personally I love designing in 3D
because you get to see it from every
single angle all the time rather than a
generic 2D shape
2D shapes are great up front but it's
not what it's going to look like in real
life you really need to see it from
every angle every axonometric possible
and just keep working through it now if
we come back to our first floor plan
turn off our Trace reference and zoom
out a little bit you'll see a number of
markers on the left hand side if you
don't see these markers you can create
them on the left either by the elevation
or the section tool today we're talking
about the elevation tool specifically
next week we'll talk about section tool
what you want to do is select your very
first elevation marker I like to start
with elevation 0 1 at the front of the
house rather than elevation 3 as it's
depicted by default here
so what I need to do is Select that
elevation marker rotate it 180 degrees
and then drag it in front of my house
typically when you document elevations
you document them from the boundary you
want to know where the natural ground
level is at the boundary and also where
it is at the house so I'm going to move
it back here for the purposes of this
and then we're going to move it a little
bit later as well
if we go to command T open up these
settings you can make this elevation
marker look like however you want
there's not that much critical
information here that we need to talk
through but what we do need to talk
about is the cut and uncut elements
whenever you're cutting through
something in elevation you don't really
want to be that's more specifically for
sections but if you are you want to
leave it as cut non-shaded uncut is
everything else visible in the actual
elevation so you can change this to a
whole bunch of different settings let's
press OK open up our elevations and you
see it's completely in color if I come
back to my floor plan open up those
settings and change this let's go color
fill non-shaded press OK double click
back on elevation zero one you'll see
once again completely changed except
what we're cutting through elevations
are something that change over time as
you progress in the construction
documentation process at the start you
probably do want to have them as a
surface texture and feel to really give
you as much information as you possibly
can for this let's leave it as colored
fill and scroll down a little bit
further
there's two more things that we want to
pay attention to here fade distance
elements if we tick that box and press
OK you'll see an additional line appear
if I go back to my elevation 1
everything behind that additional Line
is now grayed out so if you're making a
clear reference to distance for example
we only want to focus on the front of
this project here we can focus only on
the front of that project and shade out
everything else if you want to step that
you can step it as well adjust it pull
it back change it however you see fit so
you get even more context and even more
grayed out very specific to how you want
to operate now personally for this
project we don't really need it there's
not too much going on so we can untick
Cafe distance element what we want to
focus on next is our sun settings now
there's two ways to present elevations
you can present it with a custom sun
setting so every single elevation looks
to have the same Shadows over it
otherwise you can display it as per the
3D window which is accurate to your
actual surroundings and environment the
accuracy of the in 3D window is very
helpful as you design to understand and
how that sun is hitting each individual
wall so make this as a design Choice As
you move across now if we come back into
elevations what we actually need to show
is a few documentation elements in the
elevation first of all we want to show
our natural ground level so if we go
text General and
let's use boundary for example pick a
color whatever you want let's go General
drafting black we want to be able to
show where the natural ground level is
at the boundary which is exactly where
this object is cut so if we create that
line first go back to our floor plan
push in a little bit closer to the house
go back to our elevation
we can now see where the actual natural
rail level is at the house as well which
is quite a big difference between our
street and our actual house so now if we
create a secondary line go back to our
marker place that marker whatever we
want it to actually be in the project we
can actually turn off this layer so if
we go right click layout and hide layer
we don't need to see that layout but we
do need to know that we need a little
bit more Earth towards our house to make
this work so what are we going to do
there well we actually need to indicate
that on these elevations we need to tell
the builders and everybody making this
project how we're going to do that
there's a whole bunch of different ways
a whole bunch of different standards you
can do this you can simply do it as a
white fill line you can do it as Earth
you can do it as colored patterns
changes whatever you really want it to
be so in this instance literally just to
make this really really clear for
everybody I'm going to select a blue
color I'm then going to highlight
section 50 mil below this slab that
needs to be blue and then the rest of
this I'm just going to make a secondary
shape again literally just for the
purposes of this video this isn't how
you actually document documentation is
relevant to your country to your
standards everything in between but this
is how you would demonstrate that
there's a little bit more cut a little
bit more fill and additional information
required if you wanted to make that
white as well you could just to really
clear it out and then add a little bit
of text as well the text is critical so
let's start with NGL at boundary let's
change that black and then we can also
go and create a secondary note FGL for
future ground level now just like we
created these text notes we also want to
create specific notes so let's use the
line tool and turn on one of our arrows
so coming up the top scrolling all the
way across we can select our arrows we
can select that Arrow style and the
arrow color all of this personal
documentation preference however you
like it you can have an arrow you can
have a DOT you can do whatever you like
it's completely up to you guys just
simply start pointing to different
elements in your project so we want to
talk about the render we want to talk
about the doors we want to talk about
potentially the cappings and the
flashings on top of the roof when we've
annotated most of the elements we want
to talk about we want to make sure our
documentation is neat and tidy there is
a reason good architectural
documentation are what they are and
that's for the very simple fact that
they're carefully thought out from every
detail that means everything is aligned
everything is perfectly thought through
and you can see there is intention there
so let's start by adding a little bit of
a text note everything on elevations has
to do with the architectural intent
there's no structure here we're just
talking about colors materials finishes
maybe we want this glass to have black
tint so glass with black and we can
leave it that we can keep it quite
simple we don't have to go into too much
detail at this stage you can annotate
however you like next up the top we're
going to have our custom parapet capping
and what do we want it to be do we want
to be metal do we want it to be rendered
what do we actually want this to look
like on site this is where the
architecture is critical and the details
matter for me personally if it was all
rendered in Australia here I could use a
Master wall Skyline render to match wall
and that simply says to the Builder on
site that this is going to be a
completely rendered capping sealed to
the specifications and we can document
all that as we build more and more
detail onto this project with time and
as we progress we can add more and more
notes to our documentation what you'll
also see on the side
is two different elements happening
white and gray and an extension of the
actual screen these gray elements are
the extents of our elevation marker so
if I extend the elevation marker ever so
slightly further come back into my
elevation that gray becomes wide up now
this isn't really that important and
it's personal preference as you're
documenting it won't be shown when you
export this PDF so what I personally
like to do is just right click and turn
elevation range off to just make it a
lot simpler a lot cleaner next you'll
see all of our markers here on the left
at the right hand side if you press
command 7 like we did at the very very
start or control seven if you're on
Windows
you see all of these boxes here are
ticks what we want to do is untick them
to get rid of them we'll keep them
ticked if you want them when you're
documenting elevations you also want to
actually indicate where each window is
what each window is what the seals are
and much much more now if I do all of
these details we'll be here forever so
if I just show you simply what we would
intentionally do if we only had 2D lines
we would simply draw a 2d line measure
the Seal of that window to the bottom of
the house so we're going to call that
four meters for now and adjust that
there we also then want to repeat that
for the top of the window head which is
simply going to be another two meters
above that now personally I wouldn't be
doing this in 2D I'd be using the 4D
window marker which makes life so much
easier and just to Showcase how simple
it is we can select our course we can go
millimeters from Project zero let's drop
it in rotate it to where we need to be
and then we can simply
adjust it change it and it will
automatically change the heights Boris
so I wouldn't be as personally be doing
it in 2D I'd definitely been using an
automatic system like this
very similar to the door window markers
which we'll get into a little bit later
all right let's Dive Right In to our
section and our sectional details first
of all what we want to do is jump back
to our ground floor plan and see what's
happening we can undo our Trace
reference so we don't have to see the
extra bits and pieces if you zoom out a
little bit you'll see just like our
elevations we have our sections on the
left hand side pick any of your sections
let's grab section one command D and
move it across
where you cut your section completely up
to you and it's all about construction
details and construction information for
me what's going to be really important
in this section will be potentially
right here by cutting through our window
our laundry bench our laundry our
bathroom our bedroom and again another
window we're gonna see a variety of
different elements in the construction
so what we want to do is either go to
our section panel on the right hand side
to activate that section or right click
on that section and view this section
personally I'm just going to double tap
section one on the right hand side now
just like elevations you could change
all of your settings for your sections
personally sections are about
construction and construction
information I do not like having them
colored I also like to have a uniform
cut pen fills have to say it slowly on
black as well so let's do that press OK
jump back to section you see everywhere
we've cut through is shown as black
first of all when we're documenting
sections like I mentioned it's all about
structural information so what do we
want to represent what do we want to
showcase and how do we want to detail it
let's smash through this relatively
quickly to give you guys as much
information as humanly possible
first of all you want to make sure that
you're showing your boundary line and
your natural ground level so if I draw a
straight line somewhere roughly here
turn that Arrowhead off like then know
that my boundary line is sitting below
my slab depending on what kind of slab
you have it's most likely going to be
sitting a little bit above that slab as
well so let's go 50 minus so this is
that down from the slab to the ground is
50 mil you can detail all this in 3D
obviously or you can do in 2D for the
purpose of this we're just going to grab
some 2D fill we're going to go across to
our drafting fill change this to
lightweight concrete change our settings
to black and white this is going to give
us a white background and black all
about hatching what we then want to do
is start drawing out actual slab so
where it's cut across we have a slab all
the way across I want my slab to be 100
millimeters thick coming back finishing
that slab off here in Australia slabs
typically have Edge thickenings as well
slab thickening would look something
like this and it would be a two by one
ratio so you'd have a slab thickening
something similar to what I've shown
there that then would be duplicated on
the other side so we can mirror it copy
it drag it to where it needs to be use
our magic wand tool to extend that hatch
and delete what is not necessary
generally speaking we also have strip
footings in Australia depending on what
your soil conditions are so let's do 500
by 300 as a strip footing and we'll also
replicate on the other side we need to
Showcase that all of this below the
ground is Earth first of all let's
simply just draw a hatch let's bring it
to the back of the image and let's
change this into Earth I like my Earth
feel to be a lot lighter so you don't
actually see it you don't know what's
going on and I also disregard the solid
line I do want my Earth feel to be in
front of the structure but I then want
my actual slab to be in the front so I'm
going to go through select them all
bring it back to the front now we have
one section to talking about how the
building connects to the ground which is
critically important we would then most
likely have a vapor barrier so as an
example we'll just grab a dashed line or
a hidden line let's go small dashed
we'll use the blue and what we'll have
is a vapor barrier now the easiest way
is to Simply trace your slant select one
of the edges and offset that by about 50
mil bring it to the front so it's
clearly visible you have a vape barrier
here depending on where you're building
who you're building with how you're
constructing that Vapor Barrier may also
wrap around the actual strip footing so
if you extend that 20 mil around the
strip footing you will then see a clear
indication of a vapor barrier around a
strip footing now all of these are
subject to Structural Engineering your
site etc etc there's so many details
that we aren't talking about in this
section right here right now generally
speaking there is a vape barrier there
is probably some sort of insulation
there might be individual thickenings
throughout the slab to toughen up the
slab depending again on the soil
classification I've just noticed some
Shadows on my section so jump back to
ground floor plan open up my settings go
to shadows and turn that off you don't
want Shadows on each section it is
really cool structural information it is
not anything for presentation purposes
only it needs to tell the structural
story now let's imagine this was going
to be a timber frame us what would that
entitle and what would we see well first
of all we'd most likely see a very
simple Timber plate so if we just get
pure white box with an outline and we
draw a Timber plate at the bottom it
would be
a 90 by 45 mil plate and we'd have a 10
mil offset for that plasterboard and
then of course to indicate a Timber
plate here we would have a simple x
pattern if this was a steel plate it
would be a c channel or a zed purlin or
whatever it was that you were utilizing
and then we would also show where the
rest of our plates go if you want to get
really technical you might show a double
play at the bottom you'll show a plate
underneath your windowsill your shoulder
plate at the top of your windows head
and again at the top of your actual wall
now next what you'd show is most likely
insulation in that wall so if we find
insulation we can use bat insulation
change that to gray as well or change
that to Black now typically speaking
sections are not at a 1 to 100 scale
they are generally at 1 to 50 or larger
so make sure you increase your sections
and that way you can continue to move
forward now this isn't a Timber framing
code or whatever framing video at all
but you'd most likely have some sort of
header beam
over the top of your window to carry the
load support through the sides whatever
was required under your framing code
requirements same as the seal plate you
might Beef It Up do whatever you need to
do generally speaking that's what our
wall would look like and that's what we
would be showcasing for the rest of
these I'll quickly go ahead and update
all of these live floor walls so you can
see what I'm talking about now to make
sure I don't get a bunch of hate
comments on this video as well you can
speed up this process by coming in to
your section details changing from
uniform to cut fill and making sure a
uniform pen is selected by doing so and
coming back into our section you'll see
that the insulation is actually shown on
these wolves so if I was to delete this
ugly 2D hatch that I've created you'll
see the beautiful installation actually
shown whereas in the middle walls or the
internal walls you delete it and it's
empty because there is typically no
insulation besides acoustic insulation
in these walls
whereas external walls are specifically
Earth wall or something of those sorts
continuing to move up the ranks what you
will see is a Timber floor now this
floor is 300 mil wide and it is a
composite so it does have a few layers
to it very similar to what we've done
for our walls is what would happen for
this Central floor so first of all we
would have some form of ring vein 270 by
65 Timber stud on the outside now
depending on which way your floor joists
were going you could have these at 450
centers 600 centers whatever your
engineer called for it personally I love
450 centers for a Timber floor it makes
it quite solid and doesn't feel bouncy
whatsoever so it is much nicer to finish
off a Timber floor with 450 Setters and
then the odd one out is just joined to
put insulation in the easiest way is
open up the object use the insulation
drop it in rotate it and adjust it to
the right size that you need now to make
your insulation ball to the back and
your beans
actually stand through you would
obviously just make that insulation a
lighter color and push it to the back
now we have some sort of Timber
floorboard here we have nothing wrapping
underneath so we would have to Showcase
that via our clean fill
so what we could do is introduce a 10
millimeter fill and bring that to the
front as pure black and then we could
also extend that edge another 10
millimeters forward there to showcase
the edge of our Timber floor was wrapped
around it was concealed with whatever
cladding we had and we would simply move
the wall above it to a line 10 mil and
then we could extend our cladding all
the way out and by showcasing that right
there you would indicate that this
cladding goes down past your slab Edge
and then you'd have a different material
returning to the end obviously even at
once 50 that is quite hard to seed it is
nearly impossible to see so what you'd
have to do is a sexual detail
that can be easily achieved by using
your detail tool here on the left hand
side if you select the detail tool start
drawing a basic Square
try align it to only the information you
want to showcase because it will make a
2d carbon copy of this area for me I
like that shape there I'm going to click
over here and it's going to tell me that
this ID is on this layer now once you
create details you'll find them appear
in the details section so if you double
click the detail you'll see that detail
be blown up to 1 to 25 or 1 to 10 or
whatever you decide to make it then
utilizing this much larger detail will
print obviously much larger you can go
through and detail this with impeccable
accuracy you can showcase exactly the
size of your studs you can showcase your
skirtings your plasterboard how aligns
how the floorboard comes in underneath
that skirting where that particle board
stops how this ring beam is bolted to
the side what kind of cleats you're
using much much much more throughout a
residential project you may have 20 to
50 to 100 of these details depending on
how much information and how much in
architectural input you wish to place on
the project the upper walls would be
identical to lower floor walls and you
would go ahead and duplicate the same
kind of system obviously the walls would
stop at the underside of the beam or
depending on how your Carpenter wish to
brace them it could actually extend a
little bit further and then be braced in
between the actual Rafters but for the
purpose of the that is one long rafter
with some tin on top and then again
we'll Place some insulation align it to
our Rafters for basing and sizing and
away we go we have our section well
detailed well-informed and as we
progress we add more and more and more
the last thing you may want to consider
in this section is actually how we
protect the top of the roof so let's
grab one of these Timber studs drag it
to the top of this parapet here in the
timber wall what would happen in this
scenario is basically the corrugated tin
that is sitting on top right here would
have a flashing that flashing would be
cut into the corrugated tin it would
then reverse back two three four five
hundred mil depending on the weather in
the regions uh be pushed all the way up
that wall returned pressed over our
actual top of wall returned down back
and then it would either
flick a little tiny bit with a silicon
bead or wrap around and interlock into
the cladding system itself
either way you're flashing up the top
I'll just change the color for clarity
would protect the top of the wall from
any weather and any water in a section
typically you wouldn't showcase any of
the fixed Furniture so if I was to go in
turn my fixed Furniture off we would
hide all of that you can show your
plumbing fixtures if you want just
simply change those to a different color
so they aren't pink and drive me crazy
take this one step further and really
think about our construction and our
detailing these wet areas as well as
this wet area up top would most likely
be tiled which means they would most
likely be set down to allow for the
screed
and the tiling to actually be utilized
in these rooms now what do I mean by
that well first of all what we would do
is let's just align these hot spots if
we set this slab down 30 millimeters we
would then also set this section of slab
down 30 millimeters and allow a two to
one change in the grade between the
bottom of the slab what you'd see then
is approximately 20 millimeters of
screed so let's make that yellow for
clarity which will allow you to
manipulate the uneven levels of the
concrete and provide a perfectly level
surface for your tiles to go on and then
last but not least you would have 10
millimeters of tiles
which I'll make black for the purposes
of argument on top of that screen
now this wall here you would either make
sure that the concrete is stepped up
with a little bunding plate in between
the walls so that your screed creates a
natural barrier between and you only
have to waterproof up the walls Not
underneath or you could run it
underneath and do a completely different
waterproofing detail nonetheless that is
the core and most important elements of
a structural section you really need to
focus on the details the elements Zoom
right in to every little bit think about
every little connection Point how it's
going to work what's going to happen I'm
going to showcase the bolt coming
through this bottom plate doing it to
show the insulation on the side which
then results in our footings having to
move to the right hand side and being
dropped do we need to show all the Rio
do we need to show the chairs do we need
to show any hydronic in slab eating are
we going to show a drop ceiling in our
bathroom potentially we want to take
some of these potentially we want to
take some of these Timber studs drop
them 300 millimeters and create a false
ceiling for ourselves because we might
find that we need this extra space for
mechanical ventilation for additional
lighting for heating for all sorts of
things so this is where we detail how
our ceiling Heights are where they go
and what they need to be we're over the
hump so I'm skipping the intro and we're
diving straight into part 11 Door and
Window schedules now this one's a little
bit nerdy and we're going to try to keep
it relatively simple so that everybody
can work their way through this and make
sure they can replicate for themselves
first of all let's jump back to our
ground floor plan and actually Define
what we're talking about what we what we
need to do is identify each one of our
doors and our windows in our project on
both levels where to identify them with
some sort of marker so let's select the
front door it's typically where we start
with our door and window schedule and we
generally work in a clockwise pattern so
if we started our front door we can work
our way around the building and then
come back command T opens up our
settings and then down the bottom you're
going to see classifications and
properties the first thing you need to
check is that your door is actually set
to door if it's not set to door it's
just not going to show up on any of your
door and window sketch next you want to
give it an ID tag you want to call it
what you specifically want to call it
for me I like to have my door as d01 if
it's a sliding door S01 if it's a pivot
door p01 so forth Windows a kind of
similar concept w01 moving forward in
this case it is a non-load bearing
element it is positioned on the exterior
not the interior doesn't make too much
of a difference in our door window
schedule but it's nice to have there we
can either go through and update all of
our individual elements here in our
classifications and properties to
backload into our schedule or we can
create a very unique Special schedule so
first of all let's hit that ok button
let's come all the way around find the
second door open that up repeat our
process d02 non-load bearing
and exterior pressing okay last but not
least we have our door zero three which
we also want to change in name for the
purpose of this we also want to
introduce all of our windows so let's
start at the front door go to
classifications make sure that it's on
the window change that to windows01
position
exterior structural non-load bearing
okay we can go around repeat that for
all of these windows on the ground floor
so I'll quickly go and do that now and
now that we've got around tagged all of
our windows with the correct label that
we are happy with we can go and add a
door or a window tag so if you come
across to your labels on the left hand
panel you're going to find your label
tool you can open up the label settings
and go through a series of available
properties for you personally I love the
4D one it just makes sense but again not
available to everybody the easiest ones
to use is the property label or the
opening label if you want a little bit
more detail otherwise you can scroll
through test these out and see what you
like so as an example property label
let's make that all black so it's
relatively easy to understand if you
want a pointer or not it's completely up
to you guys personally I don't see so
much value in the pointer but if you
turn the pointer off you'll see a leader
line pops back into place so you're
gonna have to come into your symbol
label custom settings come across find
leader line untick that press OK and
then you will have your first door and
window schedule tag so simply by
duplicating that I can select each
individual window
click on the window to create the tag
and then drag it where I'd like it to be
positioned in this documentation package
and then you go around add them to all
those windows and make sure you're happy
with interior doors you can do very much
the same thing however I would change it
to ID 0 1 so you know that an interior
door is an interior door not
specifically a exterior door if you want
to go ahead repeat those same steps on
the Upper Floor you're most welcome to
it is going to be identical from what
you've just done on the lower floor take
note that these labels can be done for
anything you can use them for wall
schedules you can use them for floor
schedules you can use them for basically
anything that all we want to do now is
come all the way across to our right
hand panel I'll extend it out just so
you can see a little bit more we then
want to come over to our main project
map scroll down until we find schedules
open up our elements tab which is going
to hold our door list you can double
click on the door list you're going to
have a very simple Door and Window
schedule
now you've got a door list and you've
also got a door schedule which basically
creates all of these doors automatically
for you highlights and provides them in
elevation gives you the color from the
outside gives you the color from the
inside and much much more when we look
at this door and window schedule it's
relatively complicated for instance from
room and two room often isn't required
if you have a door label you know
exactly where it is and you can map it
back to that information so how do we
adjust this how do we edit it well the
first thing you want to do is come
across to scheme settings in the top
right hand corner and in scheme settings
you can click through any of these the
door list the window list the door
schedule or anything you need for us
we're talking about door schedule right
now so we don't want from Zone we can
remove it we don't want two Zone we can
remove it quite happily the quantity I'm
happy with I know I've only tagged one
as door zero one the door Leaf is very
important the width the height the seal
height and the head height all
absolutely critical the plan preview
isn't actually that critical so I tend
to actually remove the plan preview
personally and only leave some form of
elevation the frame width the framed
thickness are relatively important if
you didn't change them you have to
change them in the actual door settings
moving across to our frame Outside
Inside Leaf color and glass they are
also relatively important especially as
you document more and more into
construction you can make sure every
door is painted exactly as you need it
to be without going over the top and
trying to create some sort of ridiculous
schedule I'm going to press OK for this
in just a second to showcase the fact
that everything changes and
automatically adjusts across if I
continue to scroll across to the right
hand side open up my scheme settings
again I can then see some more details
so Leaf thickness handle height handle
offset from Edge again some of these
things are relatively important but in
reality not that critical if I was doing
this myself I would adjust if I was
doing this myself I would adjust the
leaf thickness the handle height and the
handle position as well as the handles
up in line with the frame thickness
because we're jumping from thicknesses
and specifications to Colors so we want
to group elements as best as we can hold
Open Door device is a very useful
feature as is the fire exit as is the
hardware set and lock set auto close and
opening notes so I'll leave all them for
the time being if you double click on
number of hinges it is a default text
box so you can simply just type in three
hinges press OK and it will
automatically populate with three hinges
the glass can be changed directly from
this space noting that it will
automatically change the material as
well you can also tick or untick these
fire exit boxes and your hardware and
lock and Auto close all are the same
notes would be predominantly for a
special item if you needed anything
outside of the ordinary or that was
missing if you have something that is
typically shown on all of your doors and
windows that is critical something
potentially like a weather seal let's
jump back into our scheme settings and
we can add some Fields so for instance a
door seal is non-existent and not
available for us so what will we do in
that instance well let's press OK let's
jump to our help menu and let's type in
manager if we come across to
classification manager open up our
classifications go to elements go to
openings find door and select on our
door you'll see there is a number of
different elements available to us all
we can then do is hit our property
manager tool find our openings press
plus and in this property name I'm
simply going to call it door seal means
I press OK that door seal is going to be
created at the bottom of that list now
from there we can take a little bit step
further that we can change it from a
string a number or all sorts of
different things the quickest and
easiest way is most likely an option
list and then that option list is just a
simple drop down menu what do we want do
we want to weather weather seal do we
potentially want an acoustic seal do we
need a fire seal or potentially we just
want not applicable so press OK press OK
press OK update our scheme setting once
more and we can actually search
see you this time openings door seals
double click on it it is added right
directly to the bottom I'm just going to
adjust that above our notes press OK
door seal we can see it is now available
to us but what I've done is missed a
critical step so what we need to do help
come back to property manager and
instead of going to our value definition
up the top where we typed in weather
seal we want to change our availability
for classifications simply change it to
custom
find our door tick the door box and
press OK it will add that to the
schedule on the right hand side finally
we press OK and it's going to allow us
to actually Define out where the seals
are acoustic SEALS or even our fire seal
so if there was fire seal it is a fire
door we definitely don't want it to hold
open in a fire instance Hardware we can
list it locks we can list it and notes
so forth if you wanted to go ahead and
change the hardware to some sort of drop
down menu to something that you are
continuously using throughout the day
throughout the week you can do that as
well just like we created this door
schedule you can do the exact same thing
with the windows schedule go through
adjust it exactly how you like it make
sure it has all the parameters you need
or don't need now it's time to put
everything into perspective and Export
it ready to go if we jump across to our
layout book up top you'll see we have a
series of pages and folders We also our
Master templates down below as well for
perhaps to this I'm simply just going to
open our design development folder which
is going to show you a series of
different pages so if I double click on
our drawing list for example it'll
indicate all the pages in this drawing
list it'll tell you some instructional
information
generically speaking of what it would
like you to see on this page it is
completely up to you guys how and what
you place on these Pages personally I
probably wouldn't put a satellite image
but hey up to everybody individually of
course you have the generic title block
down the bottom as well which defines
all of the information required on an
architectural documentation package now
everything you see with a little hashtag
sign certifier hashtag civil engineer if
we go into file info project info you'll
see there is a bunch of options that we
can add or deduct from so I've already
put the project name as free YouTube
course and it will populate all of that
information but if we go to certify down
below and we go
that guy and mechanical engineer we go
one man band press ok
you say it automatically changes all
that information before you export any
of these documents you obviously want to
go through all of this information cross
check make sure it is correct and make
sure that the information is up to date
at all times here you'll see replace
with your logo and can't actually do
anything you can't double click on it
you can't drag and drop and that's
because this is the actual template
Master file which is down here if we
want to find out what we're using we go
right click layout settings and we see
we're using the A1 landscape title block
if you click on that you can change the
title block to Different Page sizes as
well so if you didn't want an A1 page
you could change it and you can also
change the numbering automatically we
won't dive too far into that I did make
a separate video entirely on layouts and
title blocks so if you wish to use that
you can but if we come down to our
Master double click on our A1 landscape
title block you can see we can now click
on everything in the title block this is
part of a source and has been dragged
and dropped in so right click open
source View and it will take you
directly to that information so if we
wanted to replace that logo drag and
drop outs in there we absolutely could
no problems whatsoever going back to our
drawing list and working our way through
you'll see a01 site survey has no
information on it because we don't have
a site survey available to us so we
could either delete that page omit it or
do whatever we wish a02 automatically
has the information on our site plan now
this site plan is at a one to 200 scale
whereas personally I prefer it as a one
to 100 scale so if we double click on
our site plan
let's change this to 1 to 100 you'll see
a lot more information context become
available we can then change a few of
our settings down below so it goes into
black and white it has site plan no
filters applied we can go settings we
can go get current window view and press
OK we would then obviously go in and add
all of our extra information our
annotations our Dimensions our angles
etc etc all relatively self-explanatory
so for instance Dimension click once
click twice right click OK drag it out
to where you want and the dimension is
created that sort of stuff for the basic
documentation I won't need to go into it
is self-explanatory literally just go
through them one by one click them try
it out there is nothing special now if
we go back to our A2 site plan that will
automatically update to 1 to 100 scale
and it's slightly too big over the page
so what I'm going to do is command d
drop it down ever so slightly click on
the edges reduce the size and place it
in the center of the page because that's
just how I personally like it it's up to
you guys how you place everything how
you define it on the page and what you
put on each everything here is simply a
guide now if you are unsure of what goes
on every single page and what
information is required if you jump onto
davidtomage.com there's a link down in
the description for this as well jump
into products go to our all in one
checklist so enter into that product and
basically this will provide you with a
series of checklist items
258 checklist items in total defining
exactly what needs to be on every page
so there's a quick Glimpse in to this
checklist I have not shown these before
I try to avoid showing this information
because obviously you have to pay for it
however this is the complete one out of
two pages for sketch design and this is
the first of 10 10 pages for
construction drawings basically you need
to have all of this information on each
individual plan so we have our site plan
one to two hundred minimum scale do you
have a North Point scale bar title block
are all of your external walls columns
concrete deckings Etc annotated and
detailed if they're not you have to go
through this checklist to find out so
once they're done you simply tick all of
the boxes the PDF is incredibly reactive
I have detailed this as a black document
because I believe you should not have to
print these out you should be able to
use it digitally time and time and time
again and let's save the planet wherever
we can goes so I've used it as a
negative dock think before you print and
simply use it as a digital document as
you require again the link is in the
description if you want to grab this to
make sure you know everything that needs
to go on each individual page continuing
to work through all of the pages the
process is exact the same and quite
familiar if we click through the pages
you'll see elements start popping up in
the wrong directions so all you need to
do is drag the edges correct the
information where you need it to be
drag and drop exactly where you'd like
it to be in that page and continue
moving on if for any instance you get to
let's say elevations and information is
missing or you'd like to have something
extra on this page all you have to do is
come back to your view map find the
information that you're trying to look
for so let's say we want to show our
ground floor here for whatever reason it
doesn't really matter all you have to do
is drag drop and it will include the
ground floor plan into that page then
you simply adjust all of the information
drag it to where you need to be and you
have that ground floor showing us the
elevations or whatever you might need I
don't need that simply delete it but
that is how you would work around
information missing on the architectural
plans now there's also a number of ways
to export this PDF the simplest way is
to Simply go into this drop down menu go
show organizer
let's stretch this out ever so slightly
come across to our publishing set and
you can do it in a number of ways you
can export to a PDF you can batch render
folder structure you can also export
dwgs here as well in this instance we
could simply drag the whole thing across
right click publisher properties Define
the path let's just save that to our
desktop
press OK press ok
and we can either merge it to one PDF or
export it as multiple PDFs for me it's
easy to merge as one PDF hit the publish
button let it do its thing it may take a
while depending on how many pages you
have and how much information is there
and then go to your desktop double click
the PDF and you'll see everything has
exported as you have placed it now
obviously I haven't gone through and
detailed any of this put anything in the
correct places so you will have to do
that but all the information that you
will need is here and ready to go anyway
team that's all from me thank you so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video If did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and like
always I'll see you next Monday